Dog,
should I put this in my mct oil is a
good idea or bad idea.
How long are we going to dogs?
Depends on how long you can hold back
the flood gates of hell.
Why is that?
Is a coconut emulsified.
Mct Oil.
I will never talk to you.
Swear to God.
My Com does not look like that and it
definitely doesn't keep that well in
plastic.
Dean White,
you're so healthy.
I'm eating a lot of organic food.
Too much change too.
When my comlex wow.
Looks like elmers glue.
No,
that's not too much at all.
This is nothing wrong with us.
We were,
we were talking before for people that
just tuned in.
There was no other way to tune in now.
But unless a bug,
the studio recording us.
Um,
we were talking about the,
the drama behind taking too much mct
oil.
There's a feeling that you get like a
water bubble pops in your stomach.
Like,
oh,
Jesus.
Yeah.
It's just abortion.
Abortion.
There's some ribs crack.
Something goes wrong and then you must
get to the toilet immediately.
And I don't know why I was,
I was trying to figure it out,
like whether or not it's like the oil
itself where it lubricates,
but that doesn't make any sense because
a lot of water comes out of your body to
somehow or another.
I don't get it.
Do you ever do colonics?
No.
Not good for you ever.
Are they?
I don't know.
I don't know either.
Placebo effect is a measurable effect.
Right?
So if you think it's good for you,
maybe it is or I don't know.
But um,
I have done a couple and uh,
I don't do them anymore.
I just was like,
when I first got money I was like,
I shouldn't pay guys to like put things
in my bat.
So a guy did it,
a guy did it weird.
I'm just like,
well,
because I was thinking about,
I was like,
guys,
I know putting things in my butt was
weird.
That's weird.
It's a weird paying.
Someone I at least feel like I have a
modicum of control and can actually sort
of set boundaries.
But it's weird.
There's so many weird things going on.
It's hard to isolate what's
uncomfortable about.
I feel like putting things in the bud is
a lot like Catholic school girls in that
suppression is what,
what creates the diamond,
you know,
you know what I mean?
It's true.
Like,
it's weird because he did find a diamond
in there.
He flushed me out.
What I mean by that is,
um,
when we were kids,
we all knew the Catholic school girls
were like the biggest hose because they
had the repression.
Pendulum has to swing.
Exactly.
Yeah.
You can't hang to the right to find
equilibrium horse.
Yeah.
Catholics.
I know I did.
Jesus did for a bunch of years,
but a five slash six.
But I was,
I mean my fate was sealed away before
Catholic school.
It was just like my excuse for my
behavior,
but I went to Catholic school,
not why I was a mazda
way before then,
but it weirdly.
Yeah,
I mean there's so much transgression
within the Catholics.
Everyone was getting in trouble because
they were all sort of rebelling against
forbidden.
It is forbidden.
I think it's like the buck,
but sex,
it's the same thing.
Well,
it's funny you put it in there.
It's funny you said that because I was
thinking about you during,
but Zach,
no,
uh,
I was thinking about like,
because because I was like,
I'm coming on the show tomorrow and I
felt like La the last couple times I did
the show is like,
I feel like I was in a weirdly,
like I was talking about like,
like I just come back from Vietnam with
deformed babies and,
and I was like,
is it going to go that way or were you
talking about deformed babies again
because I'm out of deformed babies
stories and I was at the gym last night
and I know it's obvious.
I go to the gym,
a La Fitness,
I go to La fitness because I am
successful and I can afford $28 a month,
no problem.
And I was in the bathroom just like,
you know,
whatever.
And I heard this girl on the phone and
she was like,
you know,
when you see someone pacing on the phone
and you're like,
oh,
that's like a business call.
And I,
I just incapable of minding my own
business.
I was listening to her,
she was also yelling and she goes,
uh,
she was,
you know,
of the phone.
She was like,
you know,
I don't really get,
I've only been asked to do one anal
scene.
This is,
it sounds like I'm lying.
I know it sounds like the stories ally,
I've only been asked to do one anal
scene.
It went on and she's like,
and it doesn't make any sense because I
don't do anal on my personal life,
so it's really tight.
This happened in the La fitness locker
room and I was just like,
I was a gog for many reasons and uh,
I would think that that will be like
standard in La that you'd run into porn
stars you think?
And I'm sure we do all the time.
I don't hear them talking to their,
I don't hear them negotiating deals.
Like this went on for quite a long time.
She did talk about when her rent was
due.
I mean I was in there for quite a while
and it just made me think about how
grateful I am that I don't do porn,
do porn.
That's a good thing to be grateful for.
I had a friend of mine who,
uh,
his buddy was dating a porn star and it
was like no big deal.
It's no big deal.
We all have sex.
No big deal.
Yeah.
And then one day the straw that broke
the camel's back was she was going over
her contract and he was,
apparently they're,
they actually asked.
They have contracts sometimes.
Yeah.
I don't know if they always do,
but in the contract it said air tight
and he was like,
what's airtight?
And she was like,
it's a guy in every hole.
And he's like,
I'm good.
That's it.
We're done.
It's over APP.
That was that.
Was it just a one in the ass,
one of the plugs you want on the mound?
I mean,
it was,
and I couldn't stop thinking about it,
uh,
because I was of course,
like I had just,
we had been about,
I came back from
Tulsa and I had a connection and I was
like,
I've like what Bill Hicks used to call
it,
a flying saucer tour in the places only.
We're flying saucers go.
Amazing Hicks used to call it,
he would do the south.
We do the flying saucer tourists because
that's same as you.
That's how he would work out and stuff.
He would go to these like weird road
gigs.
I call it the kidnapped comedy tour,
which is what I'm leaving the airport
with the driver.
I'm like,
I'm being kidnapped,
like,
because I truly don't know if there's no
house.
I mean we were just like in the middle
of nowhere and I was like,
I'm either going to go to a casino and
do stand up or get murdered brutally.
And a field.
Is that what you're doing?
Because he knows I did a casino.
Yeah.
My Mommy's got bills,
mommy's got a lot of bills to pay.
And uh,
oh,
in this girl she just went on and on and
on.
And um,
she said something.
It was so interesting to me.
She was like a,
and it doesn't make any sense because I
don't do anal in my personal life.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
And I thought it was so interesting that
a porn star had boundaries in her
personal life and.
But she'll do it on camera,
we'll do it for money.
And I sort of.
It made me think about my boundaries.
I was like,
this girl has stronger boundaries than I
do.
It's very.
Well,
I mean it's a preference issue,
right?
Like some girls are actually like it.
Like it's a bizarre thing I've had.
I've had it come up on stage before
where people will like raise their hands
and say I love it.
Yeah,
I get it.
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna chime in too
much on this,
but I,
I agree with you.
I think some people just like to be
dirty too.
They like to be a dirty girl.
I just don't know when sex got so
boring,
just regular old set.
It's like it's got to be so weird.
Now gets a lot of it is who you're doing
it with,
why you're doing it to them.
Is it maintenance sex?
Oh,
you're really turned on,
right?
Do you really like them?
Do you want them to like you both are
mutually enamored with each other or a
mental connection to get them to be
enamored with you animals?
Yeah.
Is it to animals?
Is it pure?
Is it a power thing like that billy Joel
Song?
What's that?
We didn't have trust.
Oh yeah,
that's a good one.
Old School.
We just so desensitized from porn.
I'm fascinated by that.
Well,
there's definitely that 100 percent.
I'm doing this bit in my act now about
the loss of pubic hair that there was at
one point in time people just had pubic
hair and now it just seems like women
don't have pubic hair anymore.
Look,
I got it lasered off five years ago and
I have been freezing ever since I am.
So drinking hot tea just tried to stay.
Have you ever thought a wool pants and
shiver?
No.
I'm going to have to get a Merkin or
like plugs,
so hits your eyebrows.
Have to go to pippins guy.
So I.
it's interesting you say that.
A friend of mine,
she is more like a family,
like acquaintance and she's got a
daughter who's 15 who had her first
sexual experience at it was,
I don't think they had sex,
but a man's man,
a boy her age saw her naked,
so there's no legal issues.
There was no like don't call her most
authorities.
Normal stuff.
She came home hysterically crying after
her first.
A teenage boy saw her naked because he
saw her private area and was like,
what is that?
He had never seen pubic hair before
because he had only seen porn.
Oh my God.
And he had never seen a Lavia before
because in a lot of porn they have
labioplasty,
so he sees this like horrific chicken
gizzards.
He thinks that she's deformed or has a
giant skin tag because in porn they
don't have a lot of it that,
that comment that they get their Libya
chopped cotton.
When you see a vagina and porn that does
not have the orchid,
like an elephant ear,
whatever catcher's Mitt for,
you're watching porn.
Obviously.
That's apparently the most popular.
Yes,
I know.
Why.
What's the theory getting reason?
Why Ron?
Jeremy was a big time porn star because
like people looked at Ron,
Jeremy fucking these girls and they were
like,
Hey,
I've run aspirational.
It's not like Ryan Reynolds.
It's like I kind of looked like Ron
Jeremy and he's getting laid.
He wears a shirt and his born and if you
see these,
these women that are like 45 and still
do what I could get her.
She's in my living room.
She's an apartment forced.
I'm married to what a crazy bitch.
She's right over there.
Interesting.
So maybe just like movies,
there's like aspirational and then
there's,
you know,
relatable.
Relatable I think is a big factor with a
MILF.
Porn.
I guess for me I can,
and maybe this is my being a girl,
maybe it's being a comic,
maybe it's having a hyperactive
Amygdala.
I don't know,
but when I watch porn it's really hard
for me to separate what I'm looking at
from how the person got there and when
they're young I'm like,
she's an idiot and she had a bad
childhood and it happens.
But when they're older in lessons,
Jenna Jamison or someone who's been
doing it for a long time,
I'm like,
who at 43 starts doing its just too
tragic for me.
The jump off,
like how do you jump off the train and
when do you decide you've had enough
years on the ride?
That's the,
that would be the issue is there,
is it because they're sending so many of
them are on drugs and,
and had bad childhoods.
And I mean I can't,
I.
The only point I really am able to watch
is the so like Tom,
you know,
Tumbler Tumbler,
tumbler has great porn because it's just
an increments of like eight seconds.
Tumblr is porn.
No,
well it's,
it's like teenagers blogs about
twilight,
pinterest type collections of furniture
and stuff.
But there's,
you know,
there's also a gif files.
Exactly.
But there's also like some porn ones
that are sort of tasteful and it's only
an increment of eight seconds and it
just replays it.
So you don't have time to see the bad
furniture in the background or the,
you know,
like I can't,
I get distracted by the,
the decor,
the bed.
I'm like,
that's,
that's Ikea.
It's not assembled properly.
Like I get distracted so easily.
Like if a girl's got a tattoo on her
thigh,
all I can think about is where it's
gonna look like in 20 years.
Like I can't separate enjoying porn from
the porn stars,
bad decisions and I get worried about
them.
So this is good because it's eight
seconds and I can't.
My mind can't wander.
I get it.
And they have some that are black and
white,
which is kind of sexy.
It's already.
And it always looks consensual.
I can't really get turned on.
But because I can tell when a girl is
faking,
I can tell I've done it,
I've seen it.
I know,
you know.
So when a girl is just like overdoing it
or something,
I'm just sort of like a bummer.
So it is
a strange thing.
The overwhelming number of people that
watch other people have sex and
masturbate in history,
in the history of human beings.
There has never been more people
masturbating to other people having sex.
It's triggered.
It's fascinating.
And also I've gotten kind of obsessed
with this because I recently did a movie
where,
you know,
when you do stuff you do like focus
group testing.
And there was a scene in the movie where
Blake Griffin,
the basketball player,
really funny actor,
he's great in it,
is with successfully strong.
They're married.
And the scene was that a,
I wrote it with Neal Brennan actually,
that he walks in on his wife
masturbating in what that is,
you know,
like women walking on men,
Matt,
Matt guys rate all the time.
But how he takes it personally and you
know,
it's sort of a threat to his masculinity
and manhood and he's insulted and his
feelings are hurt and all this stuff.
And uh,
so she's at a table and there's a
computer and that's the deal.
I guess I just put my own experience
into it.
Not,
no,
I just assume everyone masturbates the
same way to the same things,
the same vibe when we played it for the
focus groups,
everyone was so confused about what was
going on when he comes in and sees her
at the desk with her hands under the
table with the computer and then she
throws the computer down and she's
freaked out.
And to me it's very obvious that she was
masturbating in the scene,
uh,
in the focus groups.
This one guy was like,
oh,
I had no idea she was masturbating.
I mean,
wherever the candles.
I was like,
what you like kit?
Like everybody masturbates so
differently.
I learned that dude masturbates with
candles.
You might have a ceremonial,
because I thought all guys masturbate
under a bridge where they belong and
then the wind were even weirder.
One woman was like,
oh,
I had no idea she was masturbating
because she wasn't in the tub.
Just so specific.
Masturbate in your own soup.
It's hard.
Like,
just,
that's what I feel about tubs
anyway.
You're not really even totally clean
your pussy and asshole soup here.
You're making tea.
It's going to take a shower after you
take a bath and you're making tea.
Puts her pussy too.
So it's just this.
I mean,
we're comics so I'm fascinated by like
people's deep dark secrets and I feel
like masturbation is that lab.
We show our lives to everyone on social
media.
You know what I eat?
You know where Mike,
your kids,
everyone.
You don't really do that,
but most people,
everything.
The one thing we don't know about
anyone,
that's how they masturbate.
Well,
I think also it highlights the problem
with those focus groups.
Those focus groups are filled with
morons because most people that are
doing a person who needs $50 cash right
now and we'll go watch a movie in the
valley for 50 bucks.
And by the way,
if you're listening to this,
you're like,
hey man,
I'm fucking normal.
I'm just broke.
It's not human.
But you know the people that you're
doing it with.
Okay.
Let's be honest.
I have a complicated relationship with
focus groups because we're comics.
I love anonymous strangers.
Feedback is how I seek the truth and
that's who I listened to.
Like I would rather anonymous strangers
feedback than like a network executive
who's like got all these,
you know,
I'm sort of preconceived ideas of what a
show should be like based on some
formulaic thing that worked 10 years
ago.
You know,
I let the involuntary laugh.
That's to me where the truth is.
So I have a complicated relationship
with focus groups because I really do
trust strangers.
Well you kind of have to,
if you're a comic,
you know,
because we're,
we have a weird art forum in that we're
one of the very few art forms that
requires other people to make it form
people we've never met and know nothing
about and put complete trust in.
Yeah.
If we don't do that,
they won't be good.
No,
just.
I mean you can't write,
you can write a few jokes on their own
and they come out really good.
Yeah.
Can never write it.
Act like have you ever.
And I know a bunch of comics that do
this,
like if I'm sitting in a vacuum,
like writing jokes,
I can be like,
oh,
this is money.
And you go,
do you know,
it's very.
I mean I feel like I'm to.
I definitely have.
I'm usually pretty close,
but there are times that it's just like
there is not a linear relationship with
what.
I think that's why you're having,
as you just put a giant scored much mct
oil.
It's like cream.
Look,
it's great.
Looks good in there.
It is good.
That is too much.
You just your,
your.
Trust me.
That's not too much.
Are you sure?
Yeah.
What I'm talking about is like I want to
know how much you drank.
A lot.
That was an overdose.
Well,
have you ever seen those smooth?
Half a bottle you've ever seen?
The smoothies that I put up on
Instagram,
I call the bulk loads.
Yes.
Those are the.
That's the problem because is also a
brand of porn by the way.
I put like a quarter of a cup of mct oil
in that.
Is there I don't know anything about.
Is there a point where your body stops
metabolizing something because it's
gotten enough of it?
Yes,
but I hit that point.
Yeah,
that's the thing.
One hundred percent.
Got It.
I get it all.
Okay,
well this,
that squirt
right there,
that little baby squared,
that's enough.
You're a monster.
You're shrek hand literally in one
squirt,
released half of that bottle.
I've never seen anything like that.
I.
I shutter at the idea of human jerking
off.
Literally feels I have sympathy for your
staff.
Strange noise and what you just did to
that bottle was intense.
You're addicted.
Needs a day off.
I'm never going to look at my hands and
never,
never touch it again.
I'm,
I'm your Dick is filing a restraining
order against your hand.
Thank God for flush loads,
but used to be our sponsor really way
back in the day.
It was our first sponsor.
Only sponsor that we had was the
flashlight.
I remember I had sort of an Aha moment
when one of my specials,
I think it was on comedy central.
You kind of find out who you are based
on who buys advertising time on your
show.
Oh yeah.
I did some special on comedy central and
the ads were all like Adam and eve.
Sex Toys.
Val Drag,
so there it is.
That's who I am.
Good to know the,
the,
the focus group thing.
I just can't imagine that no one would
understand that a woman with her hands
in her pants watching a computer
wouldn't be masturbating.
They were very confused and less guys
assume that women don't masturbate to
porn.
Yeah,
that's a good point.
I,
I don't know.
Yeah,
I don't talk about that kind of stuff
with my girlfriends and it don't know.
Nope,
we don't.
I'm not like,
what do you masturbate?
You know,
you guys don't get that all the time.
Oh yeah.
We joke about it.
No,
like we prepare some guys prepare.
I don't even talk about sex with guys,
with my girlfriends.
I talking about it on podcast.
Strangers don't talk about with your
girlfriends.
Is that odd?
It's not odd.
It's just like.
I mean I'll definitely sometimes try to
corroborate likable,
like,
Hey,
is this happening or is this just,
you know,
is this a thing?
And they're like,
you get smacked.
Yeah,
like [inaudible].
That's the new.
The posties sorry.
Oh No,
I hate the word Pussy and sexual
assault.
I don't hate it.
It just feels like it's reserved.
It's just not,
it's only for sex.
I don't use it in a colloquial way,
but I don't have another substitute for
it.
Cause Vagina is a bummer.
Vagina is like an ant.
Dad's from Mississippi.
Nonsexual.
Oh,
it's a vagina or a clinical.
Uh,
I don't have a synonym for it,
but slapping k like I always know what's
the new trend in porn because it'll,
you know,
slapping,
they'll,
you'll get like a slap that doesn't seem
like it was.
I don't know if it's like a am I in
trouble and I'm not sure what.
What am I just slapped your deck.
Would you not feel good?
I don't know why anybody would like to
get one man.
I just think guys assume that since we
give birth in that such a shocking
amount of pain that we can endure
anything.
I don't know.
It's a weird little.
Well there's something that happens in
porn for sure,
where they escalate,
where it used to be just people
having sex.
If you go back to old porn,
it would be like a secretary and a boss
and I'm so tense and the guy gives her a
back massage.
Next thing you know,
they're having just regular sex and then
somewhere along the line it became like
gagging and slapping and fucking
coughing
from one to the other,
which is super dangerous.
A Uti wait is septic infection.
That's all I can think of.
Stuff that's like you should not do in
real life.
It's they're really setting a bad
example.
Terrible example.
Guess who's having to suffer this guy?
It's us.
We're the ones that have to be like me
and then we're like,
yeah,
well,
I mean we just have to play defense
because it's.
There's always a.
What point did you watch today?
It's like,
what am I getting hit?
Am I getting what I.
can you please teach me Jujitsu just so
I can get through.
That's going to take along.
It's not something you can teach
somebody.
It's not like this is the letter a and
cursive.
I have a question.
I was thinking about this because I
always am trying to equate like our
primordial instincts that we have not
evolved past and with modern technology
and alarm systems and how we get out
those impulses in the modern world like,
you know,
did you hear about these food trucks
that were in downtown la?
They're like these awesome food trucks
who in everyday or at a different
location and guys go on twitter to find
where they are and they go,
so I'm like,
that's hunting,
right?
That's the closest thing these guys have
done hunting.
If they're not you.
Right?
That's a weird way of thinking,
isn't it?
I didn't.
I never equated that before,
but I guess kind of if men have a
primordial need to chase things and go
kill and slay or whatever it is.
So if there's an inherent need to be
violent,
let's say,
and people don't get to do what you do
and a lot of people that you talk to do,
do they.
I guess here's my question.
Do people who get the impulse to fight
out either professionally or
recreationally,
are they less violence sexually?
Like do they not need to do,
does it have to come out somewhere?
I would imagine they would be less
violence actually.
Yeah,
because they get that.
I would imagine there'd be less violent
overall agree because they get to purge
it somehow.
Yeah.
And well I think road rage when you see
people in road rage incidents,
the likelihood of them coming straight
from a Jujitsu class and having road
rage is almost zero.
Yes.
Because when I'm coming home from
Jujitsu and someone cuts me off,
I'm like,
Oh Dick,
that's it.
Duke.
So much.
You know what your threshold is for how
much violence or not even violence.
Uh,
I don't know what testosterone,
whatever it is.
More tension than releasing it.
Yeah,
I think it's more.
Most people never get to release it.
No.
Most people don't.
And I think our bodies,
I always describe our bodies as like a
leaky battery,
that we have a certain amount of reward
systems that are built into our bodies
fight and flight and worrying about,
you know,
how to gather food and worrying about
incoming tribes.
They're going to rape and kill us.
Yeah.
And I think those,
those things are just ingrained in our
DNA and they don't get met or even
addressed at all.
In modern society where you have A.
I have a friend of mine was a really bad
neck.
His neck is all fucked up and
he works at a desk all day.
He's not.
He doesn't hardly exercises.
He does look a little bit of exercise.
Then I'm like,
man,
your body has demands and you're not
meeting it,
but just sit in there with shitty
posture at your desk.
Sitting is the new smoking.
Yeah,
that's a lot of people say that.
Oh it is?
Yeah.
Well that's why we're in these chairs.
These things are called [inaudible].
They're from Ergo depot.
No,
you would be really numb.
Then you would need a slap down there.
It's very distracting.
It makes sense.
These are forcing you to sit like this,
you know?
And they noticed it.
Underwire bra today.
So that forces me to do that.
Pushes down.
Well no,
it's like it's like three harpoons that
are just.
And if you move they sort of Jam India.
What does that.
Is it a posture thing?
No,
it's just like a masochism misogynistic,
a lingerie.
So just to make your tits perky.
Yeah.
I haven't done laundry,
my cleaning lady,
so I'm improvising and wearing things
that I wouldn't normally wear and I
can't believe women wear this all the
time because I normally don't wear
underwire.
No.
Does that.
Here's,
I always wanted to know this.
Do Support Bras actually support your
breasts and keep them from starting to
sag?
Yes.
Like any part of the skit,
like you know,
if you hold something up.
So I know a lot of women who have
pendulous breasts who went to sleep so
that they don't fully get beaten down by
gravity and then you have a cadence if
you go Africa style,
there's just.
Yeah,
there's no way around that.
But this,
unless you were a sport,
this is just more like I normally never
wear underwire,
um,
because it makes me a bad person,
but because you're in pain,
I'm just,
it's just uncomfortable.
I'm used to thongs.
I've gotten numb in that area and just
had to acquiesce to them,
look,
your butt crack.
But yeah,
it's like if,
I mean basically there's a certain type
of you getting so used to my throat
today,
mct oil.
No,
but I,
I have gotten so it's amazing and I'm
just always fascinated by and we're
seeing it,
you know,
I think everyone's sort of Zeitgeisty
word right now.
Normalization or desensitization.
I'm obsessed with how we acclimate
because I think it's our human instinct
to acclimate to some kind of pain or
lower tolerance to,
um,
deal with a consistent pain or
discomfort or whatever.
We sort of have this amazing ability to
adapt.
And uh,
I didn't wear thongs,
didn't wear thongs.
I was resisting and resisting it.
Finally started wearing them.
They were so uncomfortable for a couple
months and then I forgot I had went on
and peed through one.
Once that's through,
through one.
I sat down on the toilet.
Just thought you were naked.
How little I felt it you on any kind of
medication at this time?
You know,
I should have been.
I really should have been on anti
psychotics.
I can't believe you pete.
I got the super light,
like Cammo ones.
Actually under armour makes them more
like workout ones that are are,
they're called Cammo.
I think.
They're not like a
camouflage.
Not.
I'm not hunting.
Yeah.
Under armour makes a lot of hunting
gear.
Oh,
does it now?
I didn't know that they started making.
They started.
They did not have to be the face of that
campaign.
I can't imagine why,
but if you wanted to try a new career,
it was looking for women to get involved
in hunting.
Oh really?
Yeah.
That's like a big thing like pretty
girls don't go hunting.
Is that like,
is that sexy?
Um,
I think some people think it is,
but what,
what it is,
is unusual to see these girls with full
makeup on,
with like really well applied camera on
their face.
So it's kind of obvious.
And then they have like a deadline next
to them and then they don't take these
facebook photos and it gets really
weird.
Like there was a girl,
she was pretty famous for it because she
was a cheerleader in Texas and she shot
in Lyon and like Ricky Gervais' and all
these people went crazy on,
you're attacking her.
And,
and it became the Kendall Jenner,
I think is her name.
And was that famous Kardashians?
My right.
You might.
No Way.
There's no kindle something or.
I mean that's the most endearing ever
done.
What's that?
Kendall Jones Jones is pretty close.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm so out of the loop.
Someone was trying to explore you in the
Kardashians loop.
I'd be.
Which one's the one that had the.
There it is.
There's the girl with the lion.
Like,
see?
So there's something.
There's something weird about like this
picture right here.
Look,
look at this picture.
I want to look at.
Just take a look real quick.
I've ruined like my week.
Gosh,
you'd be fun.
Sexy pose with a bow in a deadline.
Yeah.
I can't look at it.
And by the way,
that lion is,
um,
you know,
lines up with.
There's a weird thing about the hunting
lions thing too,
because a lot of them,
they're in these high fence places where
they go in.
These lines are kind of trapped in these
areas.
And sometimes they actually released a
line the day of the hunt.
So there's line had been in a cage,
Scott release the line and this woman
goes out and shoots the.
I mean,
I don't know if that was the case with
her person,
whoever,
man.
Sometimes we'll go out and shoot the
line.
The line literally has no idea what's
going on.
It's not even a free range line.
Yeah.
So to me that's a mentally ill person.
But my question for you is that,
is there something primordial about.
Because I think,
you know,
we are,
I think inherently,
and this is going to sound wrong or it's
going to sound like feminist or
whatever,
but like there's a lot of evidence that
we're a matriarchal species,
not that women should have more power,
but that were sort of designed to like
Orca whales,
lions,
like female lions do all the hunting and
the men just,
it's not economical for their energy
because they're so big to do hunting.
They'd have to kill him twice as much
food or whatever they for protection.
Yeah.
And so,
um,
and fucking and whatever.
So is there something,
a,
some sort of reptilian attraction to
seeing a woman go hunt food even though
it's ironically a lion,
you know?
No,
I don't think so.
Is it like watching a woman cook,
watching a woman cook is probably sexy,
but is watching them hunt the same thing
but I don't.
I don't think so.
Yeah.
But maybe it's just maybe a varies.
I think it's more in lines of watching a
woman cage fight.
Like there's some really pretty women.
The fight now is that because I'm always
sort of in this thing and people always
tell me like I have Alpha vibe and
that's not sexy to men or it is.
Or is it case by case or is it a
generalization?
I'm just always interested.
Well,
I think what you are is powerful and
that's scary to people that are
insecure.
You're,
you're a go getter.
You're constantly doing things and
you're like.
I would imagine that a guy who doesn't
test himself or a person who's not
accomplished would be very insecure
around someone who's got more,
more ambition and more drive and more
irons in the fire than they do so they
would feel insecure insignia,
again,
because my engine is insecurity.
It is ironic.
Yeah.
That's what fuels the fire.
But if you were secure,
would you be as ambitious or would you
be exactly the same?
I don't know if I can even entertain
that.
Hypothetical [inaudible] the idea of
being secure so far.
What if someone came out with a security
pill?
Yep,
and he took that back.
If they have that,
that's a chatterbox pill.
That's what that is.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's so let's start a business.
Dude.
I'm telling you,
man,
we need to go into business together.
I've got a good idea,
but amazing.
I know I is a co op.
That one working with vitamin company
branding out of China.
Branding.
Yeah.
You did an amazing job with your brand.
Whitney will go.
Thank you so much.
Amazing.
Even heard someone refer to you as your
brand.
Yes.
That is.
That's such a bizarre way of putting
things.
It's got such a pejorative.
We're,
but we're comics so we have an allergy
to anything corny like we can say with
like,
we can say it,
but we have to do it with like an eye
roll,
like you have a very strong brand,
but,
but part of your brand is not being the
guy who goes,
me and my brand,
part of my brand is not having a brand.
You do have one,
I guess incredibly strong,
clear one that anybody could do,
you know,
like say in one sentence,
but part of it is because you're so
authentic and anti,
like,
you know,
conscientious,
calculated marketing that the word is
anathema to your brand.
Well,
that's,
that's one of the big issues in the
quote unquote hunting community about a
lot of these girls that are involved in
this,
uh,
this hunting like you don't know.
So I'm going to explain it to you.
There's,
there's this whole movement where these
pretty girls have,
I mean,
maybe some of them are.
I mean for sure some of them are
authentic.
I don't want to discredit the ones that
are authentic,
but a lot of them
are essentially using social media.
I really want to understand the,
and this is maybe a generalization about
men and women,
but do you think women have the
DNA and the true reward system?
Are they getting dopamine from hunt?
Are they inherit hunters the same way
women like playing sports,
they would love hunting.
Interesting.
Yeah.
The same way people like very
challenging and difficult things to
offer you.
A massive reward will not do it,
but sports is.
There's teamwork which is a gives us
dopamine and adrenaline,
you know,
because I'm sort of interested in women
in general that do things like make out
with other guys when they're not
lesbians.
Just to get another guy's attention.
Girls.
I'm sorry,
what did I say?
Yes.
Make up with other girls.
Make out with other girls.
Like are women hunting because they want
to or because it's they feel socially.
I think there's both.
I mean I think we would obviously we'd
make a massive generalization.
Women do this because I hate that shit.
I hate when people say the left does
this or the right.
Does that?
She gets goofy.
Yeah.
I've never met someone that does it,
so I have no.
Right.
I know a lot of women that do a lot of
them and some of them are unquestionably
authentic,
but some of them are unquestionably
targeting social media and these
specific avenues of getting famous and
making a living and inside the hunting
community,
it's a very hotly debated subject about
like whether or not some of these women
are legit and who is legit and who's
like,
what if their knowledge it does it
matter or no,
it doesn't matter.
Why is it different than a girl grows a
fitness freak,
you know?
A girl just likes doing squats.
I mean we're designed to keep.
If we get attention for something,
our brain just keeps doing it.
There was a vice thing about that today
that I retweeted a thirsty pictures.
Yeah.
You need to answer girls.
Girls like with bras on.
I'm like,
why did they do that?
Like why do they.
Because they're getting likes.
Yeah.
Why do they have their ass hanging out
with a thong with the legs,
like sort of exposed in bed where
they're pretending that they're sleeping
and millions of people looking at them
because we like it,
you know?
Yeah.
I mean what got us attention is what
we're going to keep doing.
Hashtag Thursday.
Yeah.
Who is the perpetrator?
Is that the person doing it or the
person enabling it?
Well,
I don't want anybody to stop because I
like looking at those pictures.
Do you follow that on instagram?
I follow a lot of hoes.
Really?
What does that do for you?
Not much.
Like I follow a lot of dummies.
Two PM.
Do you want to like I pm just
specifically right after lunch and just
like blood holes after lunch and you
know there's not any buttholes on
instagram.
Instagram is all.
It has to be like pg cocktail yet.
But is that distracting,
do you think?
It's because I'm fascinated by what we
put in our brain and the sort of way of
wires our brain.
Does that just sort of make you
exacerbate the obsession with sex?
Let me,
let me go over my thing right now
because for me I follow I think more
than a thousand people.
Oh,
so this is not curated fall 1000,
224 people.
So that's what I try to do with my
instagram
feed is have it be a cascade of
humanity.
I follow people who are animal rights
activists and vegans.
You want to know people who are
bodybuilders.
I've followed people who are fighting.
I fall.
If you looked at like when I,
you know,
you do the search and the algorithm
tries to find out like why you are.
It's fucking chaos.
What the fuck I am.
There's flowers and dead deer and guys
getting head kicked and muscle cars and
it looks like I'm a fucking crazy
person,
which I probably am,
but what I do is I tried to.
If you have anything remotely
interesting,
I just follow you and then I unfollow
people all the time too.
This is interesting about you because
this to me illustrates an absence of
ego.
Like you're very.
Like I'm open to anything.
I just want to know how everybody thinks
and that's so cool because I definitely
have an ego,
but I beat the fuck out of it.
You're,
you.
It's interesting.
I mean maybe it's,
you know,
you know more than I do,
but I find that I get very threatened by
things that I didn't upset me.
Like you just saw that,
like I said,
it's like this is going to be,
my whole day is going to be dedicated to
like obsessing about,
you know,
um,
so I think I'm doing something that's
kind of under the guise of self
protection or boundaries.
But I actually ended up robbing myself a
little bit by like I went through that
discovery page and there's photos that I
don't want to see because I do a lot of
dog rescue.
And then you ended up getting a lot of
like seeing head ahead of dogs and the
Chinese dogs and I just,
I don't want to see it.
The dog festival too.
I'm hypervigilant and I'm just to like,
I have,
do,
you know,
trauma survivors.
We don't have the same ability to calm
ourselves down.
And so it just will,
all the aftermath is just too much for
me.
So I went in and I,
on the discovery page,
you can put see less photos like this.
So I'm now narrowing my,
uh,
sort of as my new puppy named Marshall
Marshall.
He's a golden retriever.
The best.
He's the sweetest,
best security system you will ever have.
The Sky for dogs.
I mean for bark.
Just having to.
Yeah,
I had a uh,
someone breaking in my house.
Is that your first dog?
No,
this was like,
you have a ton of dogs.
Yeah.
I know so much about you,
but I know nothing.
But I had this guy,
uh,
the security guy,
come to my house and he said the best
security system is putting chimes on all
of your door knobs because people to
break in,
they,
you know,
they expect an alarm and then they know
they have like three minutes or
something,
but if they open a door knob and there's
some dream catcher,
but you know,
making a bunch of noise,
they freak out.
And then.
Yeah.
And then a dog dogs are good and you've
got big dogs,
pit bulls.
Yeah,
that's a good move for sure.
Yeah.
They've taught me a lot.
You know,
for me it's like the thing with me is
that I'm not as sort of mental Adam,
the same like functional mental acumen
that you have a and all the work that I
do to try to rewire my brain.
It's very hard to practice,
uh,
in the problem,
you know,
it's very hard to practice,
uh,
you know,
without something where the
ramifications aren't going to be huge
like practicing on people.
It's just sort of,
you know,
if people are so triggering that it's
hard to get out of the fight or flight a
sort of fear mindset if you're with the
very kind of person that triggers you.
So animals are a great way for me to
work on the things that I'm working on.
How do people trigger you won't way.
Um,
I have sort of like,
just because of how I grew up,
I grew up in a alcoholic home and anyone
that has an authority sort of Vibe,
uh,
my brain and we all I think tend to kind
of do this if we're not like checking
ourselves in our,
in our conscious mind.
We recreate our childhood circumstances.
So I sometimes I,
I'm just trying to make sure I don't go
through my life where everybody's a
projection of what happened to me.
Just sort of being in this moment
instead of this network executives,
my dad and this,
you know,
the guy that runs this comedy club is my
mom,
you know,
we sort of have my,
our brains go,
I know what this is and then we start
doing her old behaviors are,
are,
you know,
the sort of um,
protection mechanisms that we developed.
And horses are actually helping me the
most with it.
But dogs help too.
Wow.
For me it's a,
it doesn't really happen anymore.
But when I was younger and places and
people that I knew when I was a loser
would make me feel like I was a loser.
Of course,
you're,
you're just time travel back and all of
a sudden you're eight years old.
I'm still a loser.
I got to get away from you.
I made it happen.
I mean,
it's just,
it's so.
And I'm working on,
you know,
I think there's a lot of advantages to
being hypersensitive.
I think that's probably what we're good
at,
what we do for a living.
We make observations.
We have to be sensitive.
We comedians,
the idea is to see things that no one
else sees.
And um,
but I find myself struggling a lot as I,
you know,
do what I do for a living when I deal
with ostensible authority figures,
recreating my childhood circumstances.
And I also had an.
I'm interested in your opinion or view
on this as a dre.
I mean,
I have a very real addiction to
adrenaline and it doesn't manifest in
mma or the kind of adrenaline that you
experienced and see.
But I had um,
epigenetic imprinting like,
which is when in the womb,
your mom has a lot of stress,
cortisol and adrenaline.
The baby gets addicted to it,
so just like crack or anything,
we can be addicted to neurochemicals.
So from a very early age I had a really
high tolerance for adrenaline and I find
myself or found myself not so much
anymore,
like in these just really traumatic
situations that um,
so that I get because adrenaline turns
into dopamine.
So
how do we prove that that's what happens
to the child?
Because I would just assume that yeah,
how much of it would just be genetic and
how much of it would be circumstantial.
And how do you prove that while this
woman's been under stress in the womb?
Because I think you would have to.
One thing you realize when you do have
children is that every kid is different.
You know,
my,
tonight we are going to stay.
It's probably different because the
first one,
the mom is probably like,
I've never done this before.
The second one,
they're like,
I got this,
you know,
by the third one that you know,
they don't give a shit.
They hardly.
Yeah,
you and the MCT oil mct and knock it
out,
lube up the box and push it out,
give it a slap,
send it on way data the year Joe Rogan
hashtags about the posts.
Yeah.
I just,
I think that there's,
there's most certainly got to be some
way that nature prepares the human for
the circumstances it's going to face as
a child.
Totally.
Michael Irvin was the first one to
explain this to me.
You know,
the football player.
He and he and I were on.
I try to stay away from football.
He's a super nice guy,
but we,
he and I were on a flight once,
just randomly to Australia.
It's one of those crazy 14 hour flights,
you know,
and we talked for a long time about this
because he's a big UFC fan and we just
started talking about people that grow
up in bad neighborhoods and children
that grow up in abusive households that
you developed this penchant for violence
like very early on,
like an addiction to violence and,
and then also he was saying that their
trigger is so much the like their wic
there,
their fuse is so much shorter person.
Yeah.
It's just like you have to be easily
wiped away.
You got to be prepared to go crazy.
Whereas someone who grows up in a really
happy healthy environment where moms on
Xanax,
everybody's fine,
you know,
and then then you like,
you can't get going,
you know,
so I wonder what's better.
Is it better to be hypersensitive and
hyper fueled and,
and always ready to sprint and then
figure out how to calm yourself?
Or is it better to be just some dough
ball with no instincts at all?
That has to toughen up.
I mean,
I think that the answer is probably
somewhere in between and the ideas to be
able to react to the circumstances.
You're in an inappropriate way,
so if you're in a dangerous situation to
be able to go zero to 60 and defend
yourself,
but if you're not in a dangerous
situation to know that and to stop
shadow boxing in a safe situation.
So for me,
I found myself.
I grew up in a dangerous situation.
I was always at war.
The war was over and I continued to
fight a war that wasn't happening.
It was one of those guys that was in
world war two and they find them on some
island outside of that.
It doesn't know.
The war's over covered in armor.
You know
this guy that was on an island,
he was on an island.
He didn't know the war was over.
He was a Japanese guy.
Wow.
He didn't know the war was over for 30
years.
He will.
He was literally Tom Hanks in it on this
island.
Wow.
That's unbelievable.
I think it was 30.
That's how.
That's how a lot of people that grew up
in dysfunctional home sort of live and
I'm done taking it out on employees,
employers,
boyfriend's friends.
It's not fair to them.
You know,
one of the first things I heard in the
12 step program I'm in is this guy said
he was leading the meeting.
He was like,
the war is over.
You lost.
This is so great.
You know,
it's like time to put the weapons down
and start living a.
it's really just being appropriate.
So if you and I,
you know,
are in a relationship and you're like,
Hey,
I got to step out and go do my podcast
and I start feeling abandoned and
scared.
That has nothing to do with you that's
gets,
that gets weird.
It's not fair to you or relationships or
whatever.
It's like I'm going to react to the
present moment instead of what happened
to me 20 years ago.
I don't want to be a puppet of like my
parents failures and I'm just trying to
figure out a way.
So there are situations where you might
have to go zero to 60 and fight for
yourself.
But knowing when those situations are
actually happening in when they're not.
Yeah,
I feel like it's better to be able to go
zero to 60 really quick and just manage
it
and I know I can do that like that.
That.
But in a conference room with three
executives is,
it's not the time my,
in my mind,
it's never the time to be in a
conference room with three executives
when I'm there,
I'm like,
okay,
let's get out of here.
Let's go.
This is all fake
talk.
There's something.
What's,
what is that like?
Is there.
Is that because you're not getting
adrenaline?
Yeah,
I'm scared to ever be them.
I'm scared to ever been locked into some
cubicle existence on a conscious level.
You never will be.
I know on a conscious level I'll never
be there.
But I know that rational fear,
I'm around people that are dying of
syphilis.
They're right there,
you know,
they're,
they're rotting away.
They've got some ebola or something.
You've got some.
So what in our field that's just called
a law school degree.
Um,
there was a guy that used to live next
door to me and I just call them bling,
bling,
bling would do,
is talk about stuff that's all he could
ever talk about.
Like all this guy would do is talk about
objects and new cars and new things in
some way.
No,
it was just,
he was retarded.
It's boring.
So it's a lack of adrenaline.
Well,
I knew that he was trapped and this guy
was working.
I think he was an attorney.
I forget what he did,
but he did.
He,
all he was doing was working towards
objects,
getting new objects.
He had a nice house.
He had a nice car,
but he's always wanted to talk about
cars and objects is done a lot of pain.
Well you left his wife and then she got
real crazy.
Yeah.
He was trying to get internal needs met
with external things.
He was also probably trying to bond with
you and he thought that was how.
Maybe that probably makes sense.
It was probably just like cars hitting
yellow,
like me,
like me.
Oh that is a depressant.
So is Jewish,
he's single,
he sounds like he's got a gut,
but whatever you fix her up or give them
this,
get them on some phen phen some leftover
from the night and get some of that mct
oil and he'll shit his belly out.
Do you remember phen phen?
Were you around during the fen phen
phen.
Phen phen was some crazy shit that they
were giving girls in the 19 nineties.
There was this one girl that I knew and
she was a very cute girl.
She had a beautiful face but she had a
food problem,
you know,
whatever the areas.
And she didn't weigh a lot.
Yeah.
I mean she wasn't giant but she was
probably five to 150 pounds.
I'm not an athlete,
but I think I know where you're going.
Yeah,
she was thick.
but not in the right way.
I got it.
Not In the right way.
Too much shadow.
Thick wide belt.
Anyway.
Got It.
I didn't see her for a long time and
then I saw her and she weighed a hundred
pounds.
I mean literally she lost 50 pounds.
Wow.
She was normal size.
I mean,
not normal size.
She was in America.
She was thin and attractive.
I was like,
what the fuck did you do?
And she's like,
oh my doctor got me unfun fan.
And I was like,
oh,
okay.
I do not remember what the actual name
of it.
Philomena is a adrenaline chemical isn't
like speed.
It's totally illegal now and people
died.
A lot of people die.
Here it is two o,
p h e n fenfluramine Finn.
When like diet pills get,
like dexa trim came out,
which I,
I,
I definitely took when I was 12.
But with.
What does that,
just like?
Caffeine?
No,
this is way harder than caffeine.
Go to lasting damage from fen phen.
But by the way,
this is gutter on adderall.
Now.
I'm not telling anybody to not be on
adderall,
but I want you to listen to me.
Everybody was on adderall.
Everybody was Dr.
told you need to be on adderall.
Yep.
You are on amphetamines.
You are on spew.
Not Get it twisted.
Don't get it twisted.
And you know,
if you're taking,
especially if you're taking it every day
or three or four times a week and you're
just going to develop a tolerance to it
and then it just becomes an addiction.
You're on speed folks.
And you might be okay with me.
Look,
you're talking to a guy just scored a
bunch of mct oil and some coffee and
actually occurring coffee.
I mean,
look,
it's like,
I mean,
I have addiction in my dna if you know,
you don't.
I mean I would just explore that.
And also,
um,
I'm trying to look at not the things I
can add,
but the things I can subtract.
So instead of taking adderall,
why don't I just stop eating sugar?
Same.
It happened.
Maybe there's some beneficial aspects of
adderall to some people.
I'm willing to go there.
But you got to understand,
I know so many moms that are on fucking
adults,
shocking dirt,
just so many of them and they're around
you and they're all like pepe.
Fascinating to me because the people I
know who take the money can't stop
moving.
Complaining about anxiety,
which I,
I'm sort of fascinated by because I
think that's kind of like,
you know,
survival of the fittest.
We are the fittest and the most anxious
one because the most anxious people and
tribes were the ones that survived
because they knew lions were,
you know.
Well,
I had to explain that to my daughter
because my daughter was worried about
some things and she,
she was asking me some questions and she
was worried about stuff and I said,
do you know why you're worried about
these things?
Go.
It's a good thing.
It's because you're smart and you're
aware of danger and you're aware of the
variables.
I go,
you're going to be fun.
but I'm like that too.
But I've just figured out how to manage
it and so I to like kind of explain
it to her.
I'm like,
you're just a smart little girl and
you're,
you're aware.
Like,
Hey,
there's a lot of fucking idiots out
here.
And some of them are on there.
Like she freaks out when she sees people
texting and driving was like,
dad's.
He's not,
he's not looking at his car.
And kills more people than drunk
driving.
Now she's right to be,
you know,
it's just being anxious about that
instead of something you can't control.
Then the brain starts going,
you know,
she's age is because like,
how do you,
how do you stop people from doing that
liquid if they do that,
and what if they hit her car?
What if they hit somebody else's car and
what happens?
Then her and I are the same person and
you know,
and that,
that makes adrenaline which makes
dopamine and you know,
it sort of becomes this outflowing
prophecy.
Our brains evolved to make anxiety feel
good on some level.
It makes us crazy.
Women that are the moms that she goes to
school with,
her kids go to school with her friends,
whether they're moms,
they're on fucking xanax too,
so they're on Xanax and they're on
amphetamines.
So delete both and you're at the same
place,
but they want to stay.
This is the way to do it.
This is the way.
Stay happy to be on Xanax because from
being scared and then,
and then and then keeps you guys.
If you can afford time wise and
financially to go to the appointment to
get xanax and adderall,
you have no actual problem.
No.
See,
the thing is they all want to go to
doctors.
They go to doctors constantly sensitive
because you.
You get this idea in your head that
you're going to find this guy and he's
got a good job and you're going to live
in a nice community and you're going to
have children and then you're going to
be happy.
My nightmare.
You realize like,
oh,
well you're just breeding and then you
know you have to find fulfillment in
your actual existence.
Your Day to day here and now.
The moment like this,
the moment,
like right now,
you have to find fulfillment in that and
it's not going to be in like bling
blings idea where you get like,
oh,
I got a boat now,
look up my boat and now I've got to
fucking this and I'm going to look at my
new watch.
Doesn't work.
No,
it doesn't work.
And You keep trying to fill that hole up
and it never.
It never gets filled.
No.
So these women start going to dog,
I've got anxiety and the doctor like
here take this is like opposable thumbs.
It's been very effective and useful in
our history.
It's like this is the first time in our
history that anxiety is not particularly
useful because we have doors and locks
and you know.
Um,
but yeah,
there's an interesting tie here.
Entitlement.
When I hear about that and look,
I've definitely been like,
I'm doing a show and I have to write a
script and I'm going to take it.
I've definitely cheated and cut corners.
That's,
I'm not cheating and cut corners.
I just mean when I'm like,
I have to finish the script in four
hours,
I'm going to take a half an adderall.
I've definitely done it,
but I know I have addiction in my dna
and I know that can get real ugly.
I've never done adderall.
What does it really?
Here's my experience.
I'm sure it's different with everybody.
My experience with adult adderall is
what I'm,
cause I,
uh,
not easily distracted.
I don't like when people diagnosed
themselves.
I have add,
I have OCD.
It's like if you had any
of those things,
you wouldn't be able to sit on a podcast
for an hour and we'll,
we'll get to that in a minute,
but go,
please go.
I just what it does for me,
and again,
it could be a placebo effect.
So many of these things that we take
maybe with the exception of
amphetamines,
but certainly antidepressants and stuff
is taking it,
is part of why it works.
Just the act of putting it in your mouth
and swallowing it.
I think placebo effect is something like
58 percent or something.
Correct me on that because I'm probably
wrong please.
Um,
but uh,
so for me,
I find if I'm at my computer,
because all these devices are all
addictive to the color of the cortisol,
the adrenaline.
So if I've got this device in front of
me,
I've got my computer and I'm writing,
writing,
writing and this dings and I'm here and
then I'm an instagram and then there's
the link and then all of a sudden I'm
reading about the apocalypse and I,
my email might be.
Exactly.
And then I'm in a fucking email thing
with it's totally a net.
Haha.
Like love you too.
See you soon.
And then I just can't end of an
exchange.
And basically when I've taken adderall
in the past I just do one thing with
more enthusiasm and it is less appealing
to me to go do other things.
The other day I put my phone down to
workout.
I worked out for an hour and a half.
I got done.
I had 37 texts to too many,
but they were probably all from me and
Krista.
Leah.
There is one thing that we can't talk
too much about this,
but one thread you realize that we also
have our own thread without you.
When we worry we're bothering you too,
Max.
Even all of our exchanges all day,
like you'll respond,
but then you won't respond for like two
days.
Oh he's too busy.
As a family we can't.
Like if his wife sees that he has 40
mixed tax mistakes at midnight,
like this is bad for his daughter asks
me sometimes.
Sometimes we're watching TV and she's
like,
who's texting you?
I'm like,
Oh fuck,
I'm a comedian,
but it's like,
why did Whitney just said you 40 tax?
Okay,
well she also sent into two other guys.
It's not.
She's ruining everyone's relationship.
A jealousy issue,
but it is a.
it's like we're,
we're a family.
This is wrong.
She's not wrong.
So there's something interesting about
sort of being on your phone with kids is
the new being drunk on your phone
because kids look at you and they think,
oh,
that device is more important than me.
I must be a real piece of shit if daddy
would rather look at that or mommy or
whatever.
Yeah.
There's an interesting that like cell
phone uses the new alcoholism.
I,
my little kid got ahold of snapchat
recently.
She's been doing these snapchat videos
are fucking hilarious.
She's my six year old is hilarious.
She doesn't.
She uses the filter so you don't.
You don't see it's her,
but she was Abraham Lincoln yesterday
and then she became an evil snowball
that she's a little fuck.
Do you care?
But she doesn't post that.
No,
no,
no.
She just leaves him on my phone.
Then I sometimes I put them up on
instagram because they're so ridiculous.
Just yesterday I started doing it,
but I mean that's a slippery slope
because they get addicted to those,
those little things and it all makes,
you know,
adrenaline.
So going back to what you're saying,
I don't think you're cheating because
you take a half an adderall to work on
a script.
It's no different than me drinking
coffee or smoking pot.
I smoked a lot of pot.
Yeah.
So if I,
if I smoke pot and.
Right.
Did I cheat too?
Right?
I mean,
I don't know.
I think it's just knowing.
I mean you said this or like knowing who
you are and what your limitations are
and what actually works for you and what
starts being,
you know,
diminished showed diminishing returns.
Like I know if I smoke pot every night,
it's not going to be as effective for me
and I'm going to be groggy.
I like,
I just,
I have some restraint about it and some
discipline.
Not on New Year's eve that was
different.
She sent me a picture for New Year's
Eve.
She looks,
you look like someone sprayed you with a
mist of sweat.
Literally.
I,
so I had a and I'll tell you about this
next time I come on because I am writing
about it in a book and I and I,
it's a long story but I had a surgery
and I don't do well on painkillers by
some miracle,
uh,
because my genetically,
my family loves me killers but I for
some reason they make me really nauseous
so,
and I was smoking weed instead,
but I was also like,
I don't know what your take on this,
but my lungs were.
I was like getting out of breath and I
was like,
let me just do these edible things.
Yeah.
Because I was just like,
I was in like a spin class or something,
which sometimes I do just for like anger
management and you fucking cracking your
enamel.
Just slamming my vagina being just
totally like,
it's really hard on the,
on the lady bits that spinning.
I can't do it too much.
It's rough.
Slam it back.
It's a hard seat and you're slamming and
tapping it back.
But there is this one class that I
really liked and I liked the instructor
and I just kind of cry and release anger
and stuff and it's painful and I'm.
Yeah.
What's your sweater?
You look,
I can get away with a cry here.
Usually it's like it's yes.
Because there's something about,
for me when I feel a certain amount of
emotional pain,
it just like opens up some kind of well
of sadness that if it didn't,
if I didn't cry it out,
it's going to come out as anger another
time.
So I'd rather just release it in a
healthy private way and pay $38 in
class.
It's $30,
bucks a class.
But yeah,
I think soul cycle is like 38 bucks if
you do it one at a time.
If you do it,
I do it in a package so it's less.
That seems super expensive.
It is,
it is.
It's a bunch of like rich publicists a
pretending that a problem.
I was in aspen and it was during the
winter and they opened up the school.
I was at the,
uh,
the,
I'm not throckmorton theatre that the.
Yeah,
that's where I stayed.
I know they have a festival there again
now.
Yeah,
it was me and Neilan and Margaret.
I think this is the first year.
It was,
what's the theme?
Nights I go,
I was sick the entire time.
Hard with that at oxygen up there.
It's like 8,000
feet above sea level.
So in town I can't,
it can't be healthy.
Well,
I think it is eventually,
but not,
not initially,
but uh,
what was my point?
You were in Aspen and we span and it
doesn't,
I didn't spend shape I've ever been in
was when I was in aspen for like a week
and I worked out everyday.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Well that's why fighters go up to big
bear and train.
Right.
And like a steamboat springs maybe or
anywhere.
It's above in Colorado.
They all do a denver.
There's a team elevate that competes up
there.
But um,
is it twice as much like you,
like if you work out 20 minutes,
does that equal the 40 minutes?
Basically tools.
Honestly,
the way they think you're supposed to do
it now,
they think you're supposed to actually
train at sea level and then sleep
altitude,
so if you could live at the base of big
bear and then drive up to big bear to
get your workouts in and then drive down
to live and sleep because the idea is.
Or The opposite.
Yeah,
drive down and get your workouts and
drive back up to live in because they
think that you get more workout,
put in sea level and then when you're
not going to tire.
Exactly.
But then your body recovers and you
acclimate to having a higher threshold.
You develop more red blood cells the
whole deal.
But anyway,
they had a spin classes up there soul
cycle and they only opened it up for
like a month.
Like they,
they,
they just rented a place for a month for
soul cycle during peak ski season.
Oh,
like a,
what is it called?
The historic just opens for a month,
like a pop up.
Like you know how they do those
halloween stores when a place closes
down?
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
Or like a Christmas tree,
they just brought in a bunch of fucking
cycles and set up a social.
I mean it might've been doing it to like
test the waters whether or not because
aspen is so much fucking money.
It's so crazy.
Every other car has a range rover and
shocked.
It's really just rich alcoholics losers.
People in minks drinking makers to pen.
Yeah.
I was shocked because my flight got
canceled and I had to stay for the day.
If I was a high end hooker,
that's where I went.
I am a pop up.
There it is.
Let's use spin an 8,000
feet.
Knows that what it is.
They call it a pop up.
That's what it was.
Yeah.
So,
um,
I don't know your take on spinning.
My chiropractor says he is going to
retire on the money that he gets from a
spinning injuries.
He's literally like people doing yoga
and spinning a how I pay my bills.
Well a lot of people do it not like
improperly and mess up their shoulders
real bad and their lower backs doing all
those downward dog.
If you mess up your shoulders from Yoga,
jump off a fucking building.
Seriously you pussy.
That's what takes you out.
How'd you break a snow dog?
Doing Yoga got daily snowboarding.
Makes Sense.
No,
it's more like people want to do yoga
for exercise,
like these type A.
People want yoga to burn 9,000
calories and get them like a huge ass,
but that's not really what yoga is
designed to do.
So there's all these new yoga classes
that are like acro yoga,
hot intense,
and you're too loose and you're trying
to do things that well.
There's no like pushups in weird
positions.
We were on one shoulder and yeah,
I don't do that kind of deal that you're
doing it perfectly.
You're going to injure yourself unless
you have a one on one instructor.
You do be crumbs.
Hot Yoga,
stretching,
flexibility.
My spine particular spine strengthening.
You don't go to yoga to get glutes.
No.
You do it too.
Yeah.
I think you got to balance even that.
I do,
I do.
Yeah.
I think you gotta be real careful with
those common atory type movements.
Yeah,
so for me soul site or like spinning is
really just to like get out anger and
like push myself.
Even crossfit,
I think crossfit can be very dangerous
because there's a lot of people that do
crossfit and they don't really have
perfect technique and they do it to
failure and you know,
you're,
you're doing these incredibly high
repetitions of power moves,
which Steve Maxwell,
who's a real world famous strength and
conditioning coach,
he's like,
that's,
he's power moves like cleans and
presses.
You're supposed to do low repetition for
them that is supposed to generate
extremes for even lower.
Pavel Tatsu,
Ilene,
who's the,
uh,
the godfather of kettlebells and
America,
we brought them over from Russia.
He believes you shouldn't do anything
more than five repetitions.
And what you do is this,
is this like,
because you know,
crossfit attracts such a type,
a overachiever type of person that the,
you know,
a desire for overachieving supersedes
the logic of what actually is effective.
Well,
there's a philosophy behind it and I
think that philosophy can be effective
for some people.
And I'm very hypocritical if I say don't
do something that causes injuries
because I've had a ton of surgeries for
martial arts and injuries from Jujitsu.
Or was it like a collision injury or was
it just over time?
Over time.
Injuries from knees getting yanked and
twisted shoulders getting popped out of
socket.
Get it from working out.
Well,
I got it from sparring.
Most of them I just feel like it's
crazy.
Like,
I mean,
not crazy.
I don't know.
I'm not an athlete,
but like to get injured while you're
practicing while you're in the thing,
you know,
you can't necessarily control that.
Well,
crossfit competitions in particularly
scary to me because there was one video
of this guy who was a,
uh,
he owned a crossfit gym and he was
involved in a competition and he was
doing these clean presses and his body
literally gave out and he dropped the
weight on the back of his neck and was
paralyzed from the rest of his life.
And there's a video of it and it's
horrific to watch.
Someone sent me one where someone's up.
What's your anal sphincter?
Came out.
I saw that one,
he was like,
lifting weights is your hobby is they're
not.
Will he set some goals and he really
wanted to achieve it and that goes to
blows asshole out like an old song.
Come back from that stitches,
painkillers time.
Probably steroids.
He's allowed to take adderall.
River sand our judgment or.
Yeah,
he should take everything whenever they
decide to take xanax.
I mean there are countries,
so over medicated.
It's terrifying.
It is terrifying.
Terrifying.
It's Tara.
It's.
Well you really see
it,
like I said in these housewives
communities because like,
or,
you know,
sleepy.
What do they call them?
Bedroom communities.
Where I go is where white people go to
breed and that's where I live.
These people out in the rain.
They raised their kids out there and
they,
there's a lot of these people that just
become medicated.
Men and women.
It's not.
I mean I talked to the women more than I
talked to the men,
but uh,
I know a lot of men that are medicated.
They're on adderall and shit.
The late great.
Robert Schimmel,
who's a great line,
I love that guy.
He accidentally took an adderall once,
told me about it.
He told me,
um,
I forget whose it was,
but he,
he grabbed a pill and he thought he had
a heart condition.
Yeah,
before the cancer.
he had,
he had a bunch of different issues and
cancer and,
and I forget what the medication he
thought it was,
but he realized after taking it wasn't
his and then it was an adderall and he's
like,
oh fuck.
So I called his doctor up and he told
us,
Dr.
Hey man,
I fucked up.
I thought it was this,
but it's adderall,
like what?
What do I do?
And the doctor said,
you're going to be fine because you're
going to be fun.
It's going to take about,
you know,
x amount of hours to wear off,
but don't worry with that dose and your
body and your body weight,
you're going to be fine.
So don't worry about it.
And he said,
I went over all my notes,
said I got a to just start organizing
all of my comedy notes.
And he goes,
I got so much work done.
It's unbelievable how perfectly,
but it starts to backfire,
so I remember when I was like,
this is working,
I kept doing it and then the aftermath
was like I couldn't fall asleep that
night and then I was even more tired the
next day,
which meant I needed to take more.
It just becomes an addiction and it
stops being that effective.
If you overuse it.
Tait Fletcher put something on his
instagram today about the strongest cup
of coffee in the world and it's from
Australia.
They made this cup of coffee that you're
supposed to sip over the course of three
to four hours and it is half alisal a
lethal dose.
Yeah,
like four Loko or.
for local though was like I have.
So I've taken out of this the strongest
coffee look at it says they're the
world's strongest cup of coffee's
outrageously caffeinated.
It has contains 80 times the amount of
caffeine in the single cup.
It's called the ass kicker coffee.
It's sold at the vicious coffee,
the vicious cafe in Australia.
So what's in it?
It has four shots of espresso,
ate ice cubes of cold brew and a half a
cup of 10 day old cold brew.
That adds up to half the amount of
caffeine needed for lethal dose.
Steve Bennington created the drink for a
nurse completing a night shift.
A lot.
My nurse to be so tired it's meant to be
sipped over three to four hours and it
took the nurse two days to finish the
drink.
She stayed up for three days after she
drank it.
She was seeing rabbits are a fucking
running around in pajamas at her house
and rising.
Everyone,
I don't know.
I mean look,
it's my goal
because I.
by the time I was like 28 or 20,
well maybe it was.
I noticed him when I was 31 because I
froze my eggs when I was 31 and this is
maybe when I noticed it that at 31 I was
on five medications while you froze your
eggs because when I froze my eggs,
they put you on a thyroid medication for
some reason.
I don't know why,
and I was on,
I think to antidepressants,
a birth control of course,
which makes me very crazy.
They had given me adderall for when I
needed it.
Um,
I had Lunesta to sleep and I just was
like,
this is,
I have more medications than someone in
a nursing home.
Like this is crazy.
And for thousands of years we've
survived without all of these bills,
like this can't be right.
And I just noticed this and I don't know
if it's what I do for a living,
you know,
but just this dismissive instead of,
hey,
learned to meditate or whatever,
someone was like,
here's a sleeping pill.
And I found myself like restless,
irritable and discontent and not
actually getting quality sleep.
And I'm on the antidote.
I don't even know.
I felt like a shell of a person,
you know.
And so that's when I sort of started
looking into all these medicaid and then
of course I was on coffee and you know,
all this other stuff.
So my body chemistry was just bananas.
And I think that a lot of people,
um,
you know,
I personally would like to sort of get
to the root of it or get ahead of my
pain.
So I'm not that housewife in 20 years
who's just taken xanax because I've got
pain or can't deal with discomfort or
anxiety like an adult.
Do you think you have pickled eggs?
Eggs?
My eggs are by the beach and Redondo,
they are doing just fine.
They're like,
yeah,
they're frozen somewhere.
A locker.
You go visit them.
I don't.
I'm a dead beat mom.
I'm a terrible mother.
I never go see them.
I wouldn't trust that they were
organized.
I don't think that is the main nightmare
that I have.
You are crazy.
My kids Chinese,
why love for that to happen actually.
But uh,
yeah,
I,
I worry about that constantly.
I mean with the Oscar mix up last night.
I mean I heard about that.
I mean,
what did they mix up my eggs with?
What happened?
They said someone one and then see it
basically born baby.
They gave him an envelope,
bless his heart.
I can't.
And I'm so hard not read anymore.
No,
it's.
They gave him the wrong envelope.
Has done nothing except be a classy
legend.
She was just like the Steve Harvey
thing.
Yes,
exactly.
Same thing.
All the memes are,
are,
uh,
the comparing them basically like Warren
Beatty's and new Steve Harvey or Warren
Beatty's of brilliant legend.
And Steve Harvey is a silly talk show
hosts.
Um,
but,
uh,
but yeah,
he,
he got the envelope for best actress and
he's so,
and he just saw Lala Land and said best,
uh,
and the entire cast of La la land went
up on stage and then they had to go,
oh,
actually it's moonlight.
And then when the producers of La La
land was a total class act,
[inaudible] and gentlemen,
and was like,
moonlight won.
And then moonlight had to come up.
It was mad.
It was like the super bowl stress level.
I fucking hate those
contests.
I really do.
I don't have a dog in the game.
Is it?
What's the expression dog in the fight?
I don't have a dog in the fight,
but I,
I,
I hate those.
I hate award shows for art.
They seemed so pretentious.
Not already one.
You have,
you bought one,
you have millions of dollars.
Movie Stars.
What is the.
Well,
I think for me,
I mean especially with the political
climate,
when people go and make political
speeches,
it's like,
okay,
how much did you donate this year?
Like what are you really do?
Like,
you know,
just making all these speeches and
talking the talk.
I hope everyone is also walking the walk
and you know,
authentic that way.
I don't know,
it's just,
it's,
it's so.
I mean I think there's something
anesthetic about it for people.
I think there's.
Look at the silly monkey,
like the diversion of dresses and
necklaces and makeup and actresses,
you know,
I think humans,
we have probably an inherent need for
that sort of diversion,
that sort of vapid.
Let's talk about dresses instead of
what's really going on.
And there's always a ribbon that you're
supposed to wear.
Yup.
What was the ribbon they had to wear
last night?
There was a blue ribbon for Eclu.
Oh,
I thought it was for the iceberg that
was breaking off.
I was like,
maybe they're too worried about that
giant iceberg the size of Manhattan
that's about to fucking die now.
It's just,
it's just,
there's so many,
you know,
and I just get frustrated sometimes.
I mean,
your,
your listeners are not the ones because
your listeners seem to all be seekers,
like who the fuck knows?
That's like saying all girls or all boys
know.
My listeners are a bunch of knuckleheads
out there that listens to you is smart I
think,
or at least definitely not true.
Aspires to be.
There's a guy right now,
you guys,
where's Kendall Jones?
Who My thongs,
Blah should be lion hunting porn.
You,
you shoot environment.
You fuck right on top of this.
I feel like that would do well to
someone buried.
Desensitized.
Um,
I mean that's what it's coming to you,
I guess these days.
Hashtag read it.
Um,
but yeah,
I'm sure it's humans have a need to just
sort of disassociate with pictures of
dresses.
Yeah,
I think there's definitely some of that.
There's definitely the pageantry people
love when people dress up in all their
best and they walked through watching
people.
Oh yeah.
Look,
it's all together.
Look at it.
Look,
oh,
she's not even happy for it.
It's like no matter what she does,
you're going to project to your shed
onto this,
but you know what I do?
I do secretly not so secretly enjoy.
I do enjoy watching people as they get
older who are clearly fucking crazy.
Keep it together.
Less and less.
Nicole Kidman was clapping like the
grinch last night.
Yes.
She was clapping.
I mean,
I don't know what that is.
I don't clap a lot because we're comics.
We don't go to shows.
I don't even clap.
Clap.
Well,
you have to clap if you have a daughter
in play constantly.
You all just filming the whole time?
No,
I club my wife films.
Clap.
Yeah.
I don't like.
I'm not a good clapper either.
I do it after sac.
Clap when you.
Good job.
Yay.
I found it out.
Look at it.
No.
Wait.
Look at this.
She also has.
She's comically Willoway.
I mean she does.
Her nails went.
I don't know.
There's something crazy.
Carpal tunnel from holding your hands
way back.
She's doing too much.
Be Chrome.
That's not good for your joints.
I am.
I do have.
I am hyper mobile.
Do you know about hypermobility?
This is a thing.
So it's a lot of western European trash
genetics that we use our joints instead
of our muscles when we move and walk and
do things.
And I got this thing called Costco.
Chondritis.
I hope I'm pronouncing that right.
It's basically when your cartilage and
flames and it was in my chest,
I can be like,
it's like a relative of plural cbds and
it's.
I did have pneumonia and didn't treat
it,
but I had so much stress in my back that
my,
uh,
the cartilage or my ribs started rubbing
I guess against each other.
And I went to this rheumatologist who is
like,
oh,
you're a hyper mobile,
which means you don't walk with your
muscles,
you walk with your joints.
That's where all of the impact goes and
you need to relearn how to walk.
So you need to cushion yourself with
your muscles.
Like you're not using your muscles.
Basic.
Yeah,
you're basically.
I walked just like a Zombie.
I walked like a monster.
I'm like,
what that mean in the beginning of the
thriller video,
just like everything's all wonky and I
was like,
um,
so that's where all and that's how he's
like,
that's why people when they're 55 have
non collision injuries.
That's why you hear about people who
like sneeze and throw them back out.
It's just,
there's so much impact over so much
amount of time.
I had to go to a [inaudible] instructor
who specializes in this and I was just
like,
had to hold a rubber band and like walk
like it was so boring that I just
stopped going.
This podcast is going to be really fun
to listen to the DM people's
interpretations when they remember
everything poorly.
Kendall Jenner killed a lion and she
can't walk right into death.
I'll do.
She's definitely on adderall.
I remember.
I would like to hear the recap,
uh,
of,
of this bike us something about the
botox in her face and reached way to her
fingertips and she couldn't keep him.
He was shitting out so much mct oil that
she actually couldn't even clap.
She,
there is something going on with him
with Nicole Kidman's,
phase two.
She's definitely shooting some stuff in
her face.
She's got some weird sort of frozen
appearance thing going on.
It's
weird to me because people accused me of
having worked in and do you see my in my
forehead I have wrinkles.
So that's sort of how,
you know,
if someone has wrinkles there that they
haven't had botox.
But when people say I had worked on,
I just,
I just tried to take it as a compliment,
but will they just assume everybody gets
work done?
That's just an assumption.
Here's what a doctor said to me because
I said to a doctor,
I had really bad under eye bags,
you know,
I was doing a TV show like bad,
like they looked like I look like Steve
Buscemi.
It was not because they just weren't
sleeping.
I wasn't sleeping and I was not eating
well.
I wasn't hydrated and as too much salt.
And genetically,
again,
my genetics are a disaster and my mom,
everybody has it.
It's fat.
I mean it's not really something.
Ice Sleep,
nothing helped.
And so,
uh,
I went to a bunch of doctors and their
solution is,
they were like,
well,
we can put filler.
They call that one guy called it a
pillar,
like we build a pillar to fill it in.
And I was like,
no,
I'm a comedian.
I can't just get a new face.
Like I,
I can't do the Joan rivers thing.
Like it's just not the carrot top or
whatever.
And uh,
and basically,
uh,
he explained to me,
I was like,
I can't have bad where I can't,
like this is not good.
Work is so obvious.
And he said something interesting what
you just said.
He was like,
you only notice the bad work.
everybody gets it done,
but the good but the good work you don't
notice.
Well,
I mean that's sort of what he had
totally.
Which he was probably just manipulating
me,
but I didn't end up doing it.
But he puts it in there.
But this is like literally,
I know I'm talking like a rapist trying
to control someone.
But in he explained to me because I was
like,
everybody just kind of looks like
swollen.
It's just been punched in the cheek,
but that's what happens when you get
filler.
Everything.
You have to build everything out.
It's becomes a,
if you do this,
you got to do this because you got to,
you know.
So once you start,
there's no going back.
And I'm actually noticing it in men a
little bit too.
Yeah,
that's.
But,
but why is that like the,
you know,
I feel like hgh,
just like the male version of Botox,
you know,
guys do like that sort of thing for me
is just something that puts your body's
hormones to the same level.
It was when you were younger.
It's not like,
but you get cut back,
you know,
you,
your metabolism increases.
Women are valued by this.
Men are sort of valued by their brute.
Right?
Yeah.
So when a guy starts botoxing his face,
like I've met guys before in their
forehead doesn't move.
I'm like,
what's going on with your forehead,
Bro?
That's how,
you know.
Yeah.
So you have wrinkles.
I have shiny,
shiny.
Yeah.
But it gets a weird shiny.
You know what else that is like,
it's just a mct covered wax figure.
It just looks weird like it's pulled in
yet because that's a couple things I've
found out.
So I am like shiny,
but I also put like oil all over my face
and sunscreen.
Well that's good.
Yeah.
And so I'm always like,
you know,
um,
but because I think that's like
preventative,
um,
and uh,
but lasering your face,
what happens when you laser your face?
Because I was like,
oh,
I'll just do laser to prevent it.
And I had a lot of sun damage but what
that does is it removes the hairs on
your face and then that's shining.
Yeah.
Oh well,
dance.
We have micro scares.
Yeah.
Little Peach Fuzz,
which is what deflects the light and
when you don't have that you get shiny.
So my dermatologist was like,
we should slow down on the laser because
you're going to look like a wax figure
and I'm already pushing it,
you know,
but I scan with the laser is like,
is it similar to like they say that
women get more wrinkles or on their face
because they met than men because men
exfoliate when they shave.
I've never thought about that.
I maybe that's why I don't have wrinkles
like men.
Men get less lines around their lips and
around the corners of their mouth.
They don't have to fake laugh as much as
we do.
They don't have to gamble at bar is all
the time.
Why is that a thing?
We're,
we're,
we're men like women to laugh at them.
It's not odd.
It's feedback,
it's feedback,
but it's not,
it doesn't the other way.
It doesn't.
It's not like a lot of now laugh at
women.
No Guy.
No,
that's,
it's,
it's making a guy laugh as an act of
aggression.
It's a competitive.
It's competitive stone thrown for me.
I'm,
well,
I already have guys.
So I've been a on this online dating
app.
Uh,
uh,
well the last one for famous people,
you told me you were on one.
Yeah,
it's that one.
That one.
Yeah,
same as people.
You can also get on there if you're rich
or have to be like a certain.
They have an approval board.
Yeah.
They have like an approval code.
Get the fuck on the approval committee.
Bunch of losers.
I don't know,
but it's,
it's a,
it's an interesting gaggle of monsters,
but I find there's something very
fascinating and you can probably answer
this guys are so mean with their openers
to me.
Like they're like,
oh,
so you think you're funny?
Huh?
Like that instead of like,
Hey,
nice to match with you.
It's usually an aggressive quip.
Yeah.
Well those guys block them.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Right away.
Yeah.
But I definitely like being funny.
Well,
I mean think about it,
it's like,
you know,
I'm always fascinated by non physical
forms of aggression.
Like eye contact is a form of aggression
and a lot of like if you walked into a
bar and made eye contact with a guy from
more than 10 seconds,
he'd be like,
oh,
I mean not just because you're Joe
Rogen,
but if you were anyone like,
eye contact is like without saying
something.
Yes.
Yes,
exactly.
Are you doing man?
Everything's cool.
Yeah,
we're,
we going to fight her.
Fuck.
There's something.
Something stablish tone.
Eye contact is fascinating.
Uh,
you know,
break dancing.
I was obsessed with break dancing for a
long time.
I cannot pop.
I'm hyper mobile,
my knees locked all the time.
But um,
by accident I wanted to make a
documentary.
I started making it in college and I
would go to these break dancing
competitions in the bronx and uh,
I was fascinated by when there's break
dance battles,
if violence goes down in the area,
kind of like what we were talking about
the other day earlier today,
this has not been a daylong pockets,
um,
that,
uh,
what are substitutes for violence or
they get the same needs met.
That violence gives us competition and,
and break dancing is one of them.
Rap Battles is one of them.
Uh,
and I think comedy is one of them.
so if comedy and a lot of my standup
comes from a place of self defense and
the implication is you're my attacker.
So I think that I probably like,
you know,
uh,
it's becomes a self fulfilling prophecy.
See,
I always imagined that your kind of
comedy comes from you being forced to
analyze your surroundings.
That is true,
that if you had to make light of
distressing,
almost like gallows humor.
Yes,
that is true.
But I did the roasts for awhile and that
is a,
uh,
a that has an aggressive form of.
He wrote back,
I did not do the roast battle.
I was a judge on one of the ones this
year,
but I used to do the,
just the rest.
You were a judge on the comedy central
one.
And we were fucking howling because
Oregon,
the comedians bar the comedy store.
And you were that young girl.
Olivia.
I love her.
Uh,
uh,
I know she's really,
she's great.
She's fucking something.
She's great.
Yeah,
and you were going on about her being
brave and overcoming like trauma and
this and that and we're like,
Jesus Christ,
Whitney,
she can't help it psychologically
analyze this young lady.
Well,
here's the thing is because roast battle
was so interesting to me because when
people aren't famous,
you just have to attack their personal
life and she was on the one that I did
recently,
the taped one and everyone was like,
Olivia has been raped by a black guy.
Then I was just like,
are we just all to pretend?
I mean because you know,
comedy is our anesthesia and we make
jokes to deflect and to not have to
really deal with that.
But I was just like,
don't get it twisted.
Like you're going to have to deal with
being raped one day.
Like we're all laughing and you're going
to get a paycheck at the end of this,
but is like an open thing.
She talked about it or it was on the one
that I would.
The taping I went to,
she was like,
and then it was like,
you know,
Mark's brother has autism and committed
suicide joke,
joke,
and I was just like,
this is too brutal.
Even this is too brutal for me because I
know the mental ramifications of this
kind of pain and we're all just
pretending like this person isn't in a
tremendous amount of pink.
She's like 20,
right.
Literally she's 20.
I met her when she was 17.
Crazy.
She came to the,
she's a beast.
She,
well that's worse than being ratio.
I mean she had even more trauma than I
thought she was out there for something.
I forget what she was out there for.
I reached out to her and I was like,
look,
let me fucking funny.
Yeah,
no,
but.
And then in I think Montreal or
something,
she fell off the stage and it ripped her
calf open and she.
And then she did the roast battle the
next night in a wheelchair.
She is a warrior,
but I as someone who.
I'm not comparing my experience to her,
but someone who is 20 who started doing
comedy,
who joked about my pain,
that shit caught up with me.
You can try it out,
run it the same way,
walked watches,
don't fix it.
And cars don't fix it.
Laughs.
Don't fix it.
Either.
Know Freddy Prince in yourself.
It doesn't work and neither does the
money.
Yeah,
it's funny.
You know it's like when you laugh at
pain and then it just becomes a joke.
The pain is still there.
It's like you didn't kill it with
laughter.
No.
You just sort of like you.
It's like throwing a bunch of gauze.
Bandages over a swimming pool or no
pool.
We'll follow up,
but it is a,
it is a temporary way I think to get
your power back over your damage or to
is to alchemize it or sublimated into
something lucrative or positive.
Like my negative experience kind of paid
for my house,
but there's a certain point and I'm
fascinated like,
you know,
cause I,
I personally think,
I mean I can't speak for every field,
but in our field in particular,
I think we've lost a couple too many
comedians to suicide that just kinda
come out of nowhere.
And everyone's like,
how did that happen?
It's like,
how do you think you heard it?
You heard him every night on the stage.
Why is this so shocking to us?
So,
uh,
you know,
I think I just,
it's not my business necessarily,
but whenever I see a young comic with
Ray,
I'm just like,
let him know if you talk about it.
Yeah.
Well that's very nice of you.
Now it makes sense because I didn't see
that I walked into the bar right when
they had finished and you or we're
dissecting.
I'm like fucking hilarious.
She can't help.
Like psychologically analyzing,
well that's like me important.
I can't enjoy porn because I'm too
worried about the girl and like why
she's doing it in comedy.
I'm,
when she's talking about being raped,
I'm just like,
should we call a helpline?
I remember I read a story about a guy
who was in porn that I'd seen in a bunch
of porn films that blew his brains out
and I was like,
whoa.
I'm like,
even the guys,
because a lot of these people that get
involved in porn,
it's like they.
They came here to be an actor and it
didn't work out and then somewhere along
the line someone said,
look,
you make $2,000
to fuck.
And they went,
all right,
I'm in.
And then back then they really could
make a lot of money doing porn.
Now it's even stranger because the money
went away.
Like there was a guy who was a porn star
and he was producing films and he just,
he lives a few doors down from me and I
was like,
wow,
this guy's ball,
these bond from porn.
And then the internet came along and you
know how the Internet crippled a lot of
industries and the people cared,
like people cared about the internet,
crippling the record industry.
Like it was a big deal.
The napster issue is a big deal.
No buddy gave a fuck about porn.
It,
it's a very strange thing.
It's like our,
our shame and watching other people have
sex.
It,
it transferred over to commerce.
Like the actual commerce of porn,
which is totally legal,
was completely and totally ignored that
industry essentially vanished and had to
regroup and refigure itself out.
And I don't understand the economics of
it.
I've never really looked into it,
but I know that they don't have DVD
sales anymore.
It's Kinda gone.
And there's also something
psychologically really annihilating
about being seen and then not being
seen.
You know,
it's like,
I mean,
I don't know what this person's
experienced as.
I can't pretend to know why that guy did
that,
but I think it was mark Burnett was
talking like reality stars.
How many of them killed themselves after
they've been,
like they have it and then it's taken
away from them or they're seen for
something and then not.
And there's something really fascinating
like Spencer,
Heidi,
yeah,
like totally.
And how you self destruct after,
you know,
humans,
we don't like things being taken away
from us but especially being seen and we
get feel safe or dopamine or whatever it
is from being seen.
And then we're not seeing anymore.
And porn is probably the most insidious
in a way because like,
I mean I even find myself and I'm not as
famous as you,
I'm like,
but when I don't know if people know me
or not,
I get,
I feel really unsafe.
So if I'm like,
if I'm sitting next to someone on a
plane and this happens kind of a lot.
And I'm like,
okay,
cool.
He doesn't recognize me.
I changed my hair color,
you know,
a lot of people don't recognize me now
and uh,
or cool and I'm doing this and I'm like
doing my dm of writing my Dick Jokes and
I'm picking my nose or doing whatever
I'm doing.
And at the end of the flight he's like,
I just want to let you know I'm a big
fan.
And I'm like,
wait,
I thought we had an agreement that we
were just strangers and now you've
completely betrayed,
like,
and then I'm like,
well,
and then I just get into this weird
hitchcock like paranoia of like,
who knows me who doesn't?
And that's my codependence I have to be
able to behave in an authentic way
whether people recognize me or not,
but it's just sort of this creepy
feeling I imagined doing porn because
way more people watch porn and then
watch anything I've ever done.
So I'd imagine so many people recognize
that guy but would never say anything.
Just this weird like secret.
Uh,
I don't know.
It feels like a very pernicious
existence.
Like not knowing who knows you and who
doesn't and everyone pretending they
don't know you.
I mean if you're,
I have a lot of people come up to me and
this was always very like weird guys
will come up to me.
They'll be like,
hey,
I don't know who you are,
but my girlfriend loves you.
So can we get a photo of like,
now you're just hurting my look what's
happening or when people are like,
so,
uh,
so what,
what do you do?
You're an intern.
Like I can tell they're pretending not
to and then I have to engage in this
weird bad improv game with and I imagine
porn stars because there's so much shame
in admitting you watch it.
People know you,
but they don't say anything yet.
I wonder if that's ever going to go
away.
The shame of admitting you watch other
people have sex and that you masturbate.
Like there's,
there's two shames.
They're watching it and there's a shame
and we'll.
Why do you watch it?
Just watch it.
Just because I'm interested in just
beating off.
You're slapping your posts that you're
doing something.
Something crazy is going on.
It's just,
it is so fascinating.
I mean it's obviously rooted in
religion.
I would imagine that it's parenting
instincts that sort of echoed from the
time that people came over in the boat.
I feel very safe when I know men
masturbate because I'm like,
you're getting your needs met in a
healthy way.
You're not just fucking holes in walls
once a month and like doing,
you know,
it's like you feel safe.
I feel safe when I know that I don't
like waiting for the other shoe to drop.
Like if I feel like if men don't
masturbate,
where is it?
Where is it where you're just gonna just
shoot someone like random,
like,
you know,
like I don't know.
I don't know.
I know,
I know a lot of guys who have stopped
masturbating and because they made them
too crazy and they've managed to go
years without it and they don't.
I can't speak for everybody.
They seem really and like,
because I think there were sick of being
like a puppet of this,
like constant.
I can't pretend to know what it's like
to know.
There's an insidious thing that happens
with human beings when they don't have
intimate interactions with people in
that way.
People that normally would come carrot
top.
Yeah.
I mean I don't know if he's.
I don't know.
I don't.
But when I see comedians who don't hang
out with other Comedians,
I'm always like,
oh,
this isn't good.
This isn't gonna go well.
Well there's a lot of comedians that are
like super competitive and they don't
like other Comedians,
which is.
It's really weird because there's so few
of us.
It's the least competitive field you can
go into in a weird way.
Yeah.
There's so much demand for comedies,
thousands of comedy clubs.
Someone else doing well helps you.
You know,
it's interesting.
I mean,
how many comedy clubs are there and how
many comedians are there?
I mean,
I'm talking about this,
like how many comedians can do an hour?
I think there's 500 working professional
headline and Comedians in this country.
I think there's maybe 500,
maybe there's a thousand and I think 500
of them probably
they can sell.
You can sell a thousand Friday.
Friday night.
Yeah.
Oh,
a thousand seats.
It goes down to one theater.
Yeah.
It goes down to what caused that
200 maybe.
Maybe 200 maybe.
Maybe.
Yeah.
$200.
I mean,
is there any other field that has that
few people besides like Tiffany Glass
makers or something?
Yeah,
like neuroscientists or something.
You know,
there's one at every college and there's
how many colleges in America,
but there's a lot of shit comics too,
just like there's probably a lot of shit
neurosurgeons,
but there is this sort of false.
I mean granted to be a comedian,
there's,
you know,
probably in fight or flight mode anyway
or some sort of competitive thing
because it's so hard to do that if you
do make it.
There's a very specific neurology there.
But the competition among comedians as
so odd to me.
Well I remember being um,
I got into it straight from fighting and
I remember being super jealous of people
that were doing well when I was just
starting out.
Like I'd see someone on stage on black
keys aren't even funny.
Why can't I get up there?
And then I recognized maybe like a
couple of years in,
in my career,
I'm like,
wow,
that is a dumb way to think.
And this is some really self.
Because I constantly would just reading
psychology books and self help books and
just constant trying to analyze my mind
because I knew that insecurity was
tripping me up.
Whether it was in fighting or whether it
was in comedy insecurity,
like a weird little demon that wrecks
havoc on them.
Met a lot of times masquerades as
confidence and ambition.
So it's hard to
sort of.
Well,
he didn't even masquerade with me,
but I would pretend it did.
That would pretend I was confident even
if I wasn't.
Yeah.
But I realized somewhere along the line
that that line of thinking was very,
very dangerous.
It was tripping me up and it was keeping
me from reaching my full potential.
So instead what I realized somewhere I
had a heart to heart with myself and I
realized like I got into comedy because
I love comedy and now all of a sudden I
don't love it anymore because when
someone's doing well,
I'd be like,
God,
why didn't I think of that?
Or why did I come up with that joke or
why he so much better than me?
And then I realized like,
oh you have to be a fan and a
practitioner,
like you have to stop and then you have
to support of the comedians and you have
to like,
it felt hard for me to say,
Hey,
I saw this guy the other night.
It was fucking brilliant.
God,
he's so funny.
And then somewhere along the line,
like a couple of years in,
I started doing that again.
I started being a fan of comedy again
and then I started running with it and
then I realized how few people did that.
And then do you think for supportive of
all the other comedians around me and
then develop like a whole clan of people
that do that.
So if you've noticed like my friends,
like all my really closest comedy
friends,
we're all super supportive.
I love that about you.
It's so,
it's so cool.
And,
but how did you like,
did you have to get a,
like a lot of success before that
happened?
Or is that why you success?
That's probably part of it.
Yeah,
it definitely happened before my
success.
I was helping people when I was
terrible.
I wasn't doing well,
you know,
but I was,
I realized that there was something
wrong with my thinking.
Yeah,
it's the same as martial arts.
Like you don't get good by denying that
other people are good at good at
respecting the fact that other people
are good looking at yourself and your
objective analysis of your own skills.
And they realized like,
wow,
I got a lot of work to do to reach that
guy's level.
Well,
yeah.
And I was like,
look at me.
Like,
you know,
and I definitely had that in the
beginning a lot to where,
I mean I was in the beginning for me,
there was so much about just dealing
with aggressive people and recreating my
childhood circumstances.
You weren't really there when I first
started the comedy store.
You sort of had your respite from the
comedy store.
But I had,
I was hazed so hard and I,
Oh uh,
we're fine now and we are totally
friends now.
But Ran David Taylor.
Oh David has female issues and we're
fine now.
And we worked through it.
It was really hard for a long time.
But Ari has already never told you the
story about how he hit my backpack.
No amazing story where every night when
I would go on stage,
you know,
there's like,
like in the comedy store,
original room,
which is sort of our,
at least my kind of like,
it was my church and a lot of ways in my
home.
I'm sick as that sounds like there's a
back booth like that back row of booths.
It's kind of for VIP and Mitzi shore
when she would come in and then there's
that hallway in the back where they put
drinks up.
So I would have a backpack every night I
would go in,
I would put my backpack up there because
it was super dark in there.
And One night I was onstage at some
comical,
like one in the morning slot.
Like after Don Maurice was like,
was what I would sort of go up.
And uh,
I had just had my wallet stolen or my
house broken into and someone stole my
wallet like two days before.
So it was already in fight or flight
mode.
And I got offstage and I couldn't find
my backpack and I'm like running around
and you know,
it's so dark in there,
I'm like,
look.
And I,
I got so scared that someone was.
Because basically what a security person
that helped me said someone who you're
probably with all the time,
took your credit card,
copied it,
and then put it back in your wallet.
Like because someone had mentioned there
was a big Bank of America scandal where
they copied like 2000 credit cards and
you know,
it was that,
it was,
I was a part of that.
So I got in my head that there was
someone in my life around me who took my
credit card and like copied it.
And so I was freaking out and everyone
thought it was probably so funny.
And then I started crying like
hysterically,
like freaking out crying and what's
already selling me crying.
He was like,
I'm not owning up to this,
just like fuck this.
So he just,
he just,
he told me later like we just thought it
was an aneurysm prank and thought it
would be funny.
But then you started crying and then he
didn't even give me your backpack when
she started crying member.
We have to ask Ari how it ended up
because I did his podcast a couple of
years ago and he told me you can't ask
red because red is hiding.
I don't know if you know this,
but no.
Listen,
I'm going to play this for everybody
because I'm like,
I've been playing rts a voicemail
message because when you call him up,
it says at the subscribers request,
incoming calls have been blocked.
He hasn't paid his bill.
No,
no,
no.
Incorrect.
Our.
He decided to go rogue and he decided to
go completely off the grid for a couple
of months now.
He was in Miami.
Mr.
And now apparently he's in some South
American company country.
Hold on a second.
This phone does not accept incoming
calls.
Message.
See a one to seven.
Okay.
Well that's normal.
That might mean that he's back state
side because last week it was in
Spanish.
When you'd call him up,
it would be a Spanish.
You can't message them or anything.
Nothing.
No.
No email.
No nothing.
Yes.
What's this?
What's this for?
Fucked up and hung out with Henry
rollins.
That's what happened.
He fucked up and hung out with Henry
Rollins,
Henry Rollins,
who is fucking crazy.
Yeah.
Speaking of adderall and you know he's
not on.
I don't know.
I have no idea.
He was he,
he was on Ritalin,
right?
Ritalin,
Ritalin or know what it.
Was it Ritalin?
He was on Ritalin when he was disagree.
This is what,
when he was really young,
he was like a test subject from five to
17.
His family put him on Ritalin.
Is Doctors,
whatever.
Whoever it was.
That was heartbreaking.
But he would be like all day,
be like gritting his teeth and holy,
and then after school was over,
you'd be like,
he's fucked.
So anyway,
what he does is Henry rollins has the
hardest time dealing with human beings
and not being in motion.
Like he wrote this thing about how he
gets into deep depression,
like it comes to studying into his
chest.
Whenever he's not doing something
running,
he can't chill.
He's got to go to site.
I heard him on a podcast talking about
how his assistant makes up fake work for
him,
like for just to keep them busy,
like you have to drive out to this thing
and pick up this thing.
Like he,
she makes things just so she hates being
as assistant
manager and he was.
I'm sorry,
Heidi.
Sorry.
Spreadsheet.
You explained it to me.
I hate when people say assistant.
I said that I say it.
Sorry.
No you didn't.
We're talking about other people.
So tricia is,
she's like,
I got like a warning shot.
She fires me.
Don't call me assistant motherfucker
like okay,
got it.
Um,
so henry picks a spot.
He'll just go,
how about Bali?
And he'll call his travel agent.
The travel agent says,
yeah,
we can get you out about,
by the way,
only flies economy because even though
he's fucking wealthiest shit drives a
shitty Mazda six.
Is that like a masochistic thing?
Yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
Great tee shirts only doesn't probably
doesn't own a suit.
Still in like crazy shape.
He's in good shape.
Got It.
He's not like jacked anymore apparently
at a bunch of injuries because he was
battling lifting for.
Yeah.
Anyway,
so he had a podcast that he did with
Ari,
which has an amazing podcast.
We're already in him,
met.
I feel like they were in Scotland.
Was it always in Scotland?
Edinburgh,
Edinburgh fest and they started talking
in the podcast.
Amazing because Henry was talking about
how he's been doing this.
He's been to over 100 countries.
He travels all over the world and does
it every year and he does it.
He goes completely off the grid when he
does it.
He just goes there and he brings his
laptop and his camera.
It takes pictures of people and people
going,
what are you doing here?
And he's like,
I'm here for to meet you man.
And it just meets people and goes places
and hangs out with better wins and goes
into the fucking desert and winds up in
dangerous places and dangerous
situations.
But then comes back and has these
amazing stories from it.
So Ari just released his or just
recorded his latest,
our and had decided that he really needs
to do something radical to generate new
material.
He had spent a month in China last year
and he came up with a bunch of material
from that.
So he decided,
I'm just gonna not talk to people.
I'm going to not talk to my friends.
I'm not going to talk to anybody.
I'm not going to use my cell phone.
I'm just going to live.
I'm just going to go completely off the
grid and travel the world.
And so,
you know,
he makes a shit ton of money now he's
got his comedy central show.
He's,
he's done really well with stand up over
the last few years and,
which is great to see.
But this thought know it's,
I,
you look,
I mean there's something to be said for
it.
I mean,
I feel like our brains are so cluttered
with chores and route,
you know,
we were so routinized at this point.
It's like there's something to be said
for just completely rewiring,
you know?
It's just like,
oh,
he's crazy though.
Yeah,
I was going to say I also,
I'm in this jumpstart program where it's
like human connection is what keeps us
sane.
You know,
when I'm alone and isolate like that,
bad,
bad things will happen.
Well are you won't use a smartphone
anymore because he's addicted to it.
He's like,
it's due to a directive.
It's amazing that he's able to course
correct that.
He's smartest,
smartest Joel silver uses a flip phone.
Does he ruined?
He gets so much done because it's not
like dumb text ages.
Phone calls,
handles it.
Phone call,
use a little dumb little lg flip phone.
I mean
that's all well and good,
but you know what I do?
I put my fucking phone down.
There's another level of discipline.
I don't have to just,
you know,
abstain entirely.
Can you just do that every hour?
I put my phone in the other room and
then I go do stuff.
How do you have so much self control?
I don't know.
I just do,
but it takes a certain warrior to be
able to do that,
but I don't do it all the time.
Like sometimes somebody has told me,
hey,
put your phone down with my wife will
tell me that.
Put your phone down.
You're right.
Yeah.
But put your attitude.
But I do understand it.
Yeah.
Personally I like,
I'm not,
I'm not denying it.
Sometimes you have to just stay awake.
I just have to stay awake because I get
real zod me real fast.
Way Better at putting my laptop down.
Yeah.
Because I used to have an issue with
like I would just be constantly going on
youtube and search and different
websites and then you go in those
youtube spirals that take you down,
down,
down in a spiral of watching people pop
zits.
Oh have you seen Dr Pimple popper,
instagram dot.
I can go straight to it.
Jamie and I was watching all the zits
get popped for like a good two and a
half hours.
But then you know in your,
when you go to youtube and it says
suggestions for you,
then you find out the next day what you
did for me.
I know I have to get the fuck away from
the computer when I get down to animal
attacks.
We'll go,
go to a good one.
She's got some are called confetti
streamers,
the ones that are small and they just
come out for like a minute.
She's got some ones that are just
horrific.
The right hand side,
right hand side,
upper,
upper right there,
right there.
Go to this one.
She gets a lot of cysts.
Click on that place.
Looking at.
Oh well that's like a pool.
Here comes puss.
Yeah.
I mean some of them come out and they
come up like goddamn volcanoes.
What is.
So is that fat globules?
That is.
Oh,
it looks like it literally looks like a
deer has given her.
Some of them come out and they just
cream cheese.
She's got some other ones on her pay.
Let me look at that.
Five hundred and 79,000
views.
I think she has millions of followers.
More fascinating than.
Oh,
she's probably got more followers than
you and I combined click to see what.
How many followers in wrong?
Twenty 3 million.
Two point three.
Oh,
but you know,
she only had like 1 million job.
Oh,
the doctors.
Dermatologists.
Genius was the clit.
Start filming this well,
and she specializes in puffing.
Probably some dude's got some.
Her name is Sandra Lee.
Uh,
some dudes got some fucking want your
life.
Do you know that a grooming for women
releases endorphins in our brain?
I mean,
does your wife tried to pop your assets?
Were in grounds?
Really?
Know I don't really have any.
Well,
you're flawless.
Totally not flawless.
Look at that.
That's a baby.
Aliens are twins.
Plus I look at the smaller ones.
Look up to this one.
How about this one?
Is this one?
Okay.
Pull it out like it was hamburger meat.
How about this one?
This.
I can't.
All right.
I
can do like this better.
Or like these.
What's better?
This or that?
Those are my favorite.
That's my favorite.
I do that on airplanes in the bathroom.
So the nose,
that's my favorite.
Oh,
I love it.
is it?
Oh,
there aren't a lot of it.
Is it harder to watch that like this?
Or is it hard to watch the deadline
deadline,
the deadline.
This.
I'll watch all they did.
Animal,
you know,
here's my,
the,
your whole approach to hunting is.
I get it like you have a very honorable,
uh,
you have a lot of um,
you know,
you treat on some level then with like
dignity and into,
and you have integrity about it.
You know,
eat meat.
I do eat meat.
Yeah.
So I had eating disorders so I can't
really like when I start restricting
things are going,
I don't need this.
I don't need that.
That can go down like a bad spiral.
I don't actively like seek out meat and
I don't eat pork really,
but I can't like start being too
abstemious pork.
I don't eat pork.
Just I don't want to like you.
All of your listeners I think would
probably think I'm very annoyed.
I'm going to get a lot of like a troll.
Don't worry about that.
It's just once at you.
I mean I think I've just too down the
rabbit hole of learning about the
emotional document and capacity of pigs
and dogs that it's just kind of like a
bummer.
Very smart,
very smart,
and very emotional.
You know,
they say they're like toddlers.
You got to be around wild pigs.
Wild pigs are monster feral tags.
I'm sure yes,
but ones that are just raised and killed
and there's also a lot of like,
maybe this is too metaphysical or
whatever,
but like they know what's happening and
I just,
it's more like you're just eating fear,
so their adrenaline and cortisol just
like,
you know,
throbs through their bodies while
they're getting killed and they just,
they live in fear their entire lives and
there's just,
you're ingesting that and it's an
energy,
you know,
and you know what's fucked and the
antibiotics are crazy.
My Dad has antibiotic resistance right
now,
which I think is going to be part of the
next sort of horrific things that we
can't control.
Where technology has sort of taken over.
Do you think it's from doctors or from
lifestyle?
It's definitely from doctors as well.
Being over prescribed antibiotics every
time you have a cold,
every time you have at this take
antibiotics and then by the time you
actually need them,
they don't work anymore.
And that's where the situation my dad is
in.
There's a thing that they're just
researching recently on Komodo dragons
and they're looking to Komodo dragons.
I think there's enzymes in their blood
that they think is going to be effective
in treating people that have resistance
to antibiotics for diseases,
bananas.
That was real.
That was today.
I was reading that.
Yeah,
it's bananas and I also look.
It's like again,
you know,
refer me and I'm not generalizing about
everybody.
I know this.
For me,
a lot of things are projections and so
for me,
like when an animal is helpless,
I see myself as a helpless child and
when I see something in a cage,
maybe the same way that like when you go
into a room of executives,
you're like,
I don't want to be this.
When I see something in a cage,
I just something that's voiceless and
helpless.
That's what a kid is.
So it just triggers like a lot of stuff.
I can't go to the pound.
I'll have 100,000
dogs.
I just can't do it.
I do so much animal rescue and I send
someone to go.
When I see one that I'm going to rescue,
they go and get them for me because I'll
just,
I'll lose my mind.
I'll take them all home,
get a horse.
I just got where it.
Yeah.
So I'm Joe.
That's why I'm here today.
I feel like he totally,
he's a,
uh,
at the ha ha.
Um,
but uh,
he was a show horse who,
dressage horse who,
you know,
after a while they're just useless or
like race horses kind of.
So,
um,
he was going to be a put down and I do
equine therapy anyway.
Someone's like,
do you want them?
And I was like,
yeah,
my teacher.
So there's this,
um,
I think you will find this interesting.
I find it fascinating.
I'm horses don't value anything that we
value money,
prestige,
clout,
I MDB meter,
house,
they don't care about anything.
Anything that we use to defend
ourselves,
uh,
being funny,
being smart,
they don't care about it.
The only thing they care about is
authenticity.
So basically,
um,
horses serve kind of as mirrors to your
flaws and yeah,
inauthenticity.
Yeah.
So if you're fake horse recognized,
they don't understand,
they're repelled by it.
So if you got a horse around with one of
the real housewives from Beverly Hills
and just kill it would kick us out from
the faith as what I.
um,
but uh,
so I mean there's a difference.
There's this,
um,
it's,
it's based on this philosophy called
being with horses by this German woman.
Her name is Sabine,
I don't remember her last name,
but this place called the reflective
horse is where I keep it in Topanga
Canyon and you know,
like,
as you know,
therapies used for a lot of people in
Rehab and sexual abuse victims.
Um,
I'm working with this organization
called she heard power and Beth behrs
who I work with is I'm sort of running
it and it's letting because humans can
be so triggering for drug addicts and
trauma survivors that,
like,
for me,
therapy stopped,
uh,
being able to work because I was so
triggered by therapists.
I found myself lying to them.
I find,
found myself like literally trying to
manage their in like,
you know,
I didn't want them to think I was crazy.
Like it was just,
you're the most awesome and crazy person
at the same time I've ever met,
but it's like we all do the shit.
But then I was resentful because I'm
like,
I'm fucking paying you and that's all
you're going to say.
Like I was combative to them.
I was,
I was.
Well,
because it's like I'm very,
I'm not selfish about my time,
but I have a healthy understanding about
what is a waste of time.
And I found a great therapist now who is
like a bad ass and she's like,
you know,
she's five,
two and whereas only mink coats and
pajamas,
she's awesome.
She's,
well,
they're like pho for like vests.
Um,
and so,
but then I was just,
I would get very,
like you and the executive room,
like I would be in a therapist office
and it'd be like Harvard Business
School.
I'm like,
this fucking guy doesn't know anything
about problems.
Fuck this guy.
Like I just was like,
I get angry at them and then all of a
sudden they'd be like,
authority figures to me.
And that trigger it was,
it was just like.
And then I felt weird talking about
boundary stuff or sexual stuff and I
don't,
you know,
the shame that comes with saying I
watched porn or this or that,
like it just wasn't working for me.
And then equine therapy,
you essentially,
um,
it's not about dominating the horse and
it really illuminates,
you know,
our instinct to control and be perfect
and achieve and those are sort of the
things I'm working on right now.
Like,
like I have like crippling perfectionism
where I feel like you and I have been,
you have,
but you're interesting because you're
one of the few people I know who's
incredibly successful but you don't seem
to have a perfectionism issue like you
achieve a lot without an obsessed about
achieving.
Does that make sense?
I have a perfectionism issue and like
with writing this new our,
like we've been texting about this,
you're like doing a couple of guys.
I was trying to come to this house and
I'm like,
yes I do.
But I don't have a new.
Like I can't get.
You only have to do whatever you want to
do at the ice house.
You can do 10 minutes or 15,
but I'm like,
if I don't do it perfectly,
I know.
That's so crazy.
It's crazy.
Yes.
Because in my household I only got
rewarded for being perfect.
There's no perfect in comedy,
no such thing.
It's a,
it's a 100 percent.
So this is why,
like with horses,
if you're trying to be perfect or
control the outcome and you can't
control a horse there,
the thousand pounds,
you can't,
they,
if they're,
you know,
when you're alone with it in a ring,
not dominating it or controlling it or
using any kind of,
um,
a manipulation devices,
you really can only be authentic and
detach from the results of like,
I need the horse to run and jump and do
all these things.
They're not going to do what you in your
mind think is perfect.
So it's about like detaching from
results.
Let me ease your concerns because I
definitely have perfection issues.
How?
But I just let them go.
Well,
I,
I don't like anything.
I do really almost nothing.
I don't like any of my comedy.
I don't watch anything I do because I
break it down so much.
I go over it so much.
You get sick of it.
I make notes.
Yeah.
I go over to change things.
If we flub a word,
I want to jump into an oncoming train.
The audience loves it.
They're like,
he's human.
He flubs herds like,
well,
if I recover it's fun,
but there's,
I just,
it bothers me when I don't do something
right.
And he definitely bothers me,
but I've learned how to manage that
bother over the years where it doesn't.
I don't go crazy.
Yeah,
and I think part of that is,
I don't know if there's a lot of factors
there.
Part of it is understanding that it's an
issue and then figuring out why and then
I'd spend a lot of time doing things
like meditating or taking a lot of yoga.
I do occasionally again in my isolation
tank and work things out in there.
When I do yoga,
I,
I can't eat because I'm so like need to
be doing it per like,
I,
you know,
and it comes and goes,
but it really is.
Especially when I'm,
I'm like get really busy and like out of
control and out of touch,
like I resort to my is what gets me
attention and that's how I will survive
very like primitive thinking because
that's what worked for me as a child.
Well,
it seems like you're all,
you're aware of all these issues which
is like step at least step one.
Well I think the real thing and,
and your proof that you can do it as
like,
can you release your protection
mechanisms or the things that worked for
you or the things that.
Because I think a lot of my
perfectionism has worked in a lot of
ways.
I have achieved things and because of
it,
but it has started to actually hold me
back.
So can you,
the thing,
the sort of maladaptive behavior that
has worked for you professionally,
can you release it and still will you,
you are also,
you're single and your,
um,
your,
you're not finding people that are
competitive.
I love that you just said that because
I'm finding it was bleeding into my
dating.
I was like,
you're not like,
you know,
I think a lot of dating as being able to
just go like,
I'm flawed,
you're flawed.
I'm going to stop picking you apart.
Like.
Because I think there's an overachiever
mentality that sometimes bleeds into our
personal life of like,
but what if there's someone better?
Well,
if you don't feel safe to,
you also have predatory instincts.
Will you find that were week thing and
you're like,
look at that.
And Scott got a wimp.
You know,
he's got a mental limp.
Yes.
Yeah.
And then you go,
oh,
he might be full of shit or he might be
pretending he's something he's not.
Or he might be.
Totally.
Yeah,
totally.
But like,
that's so am I.
sometimes,
you know,
I've done that.
I do that,
you know,
at what point do you just commit and
accept like,
um,
somebody and I don't,
I don't know the answer.
Well,
it's going to be hard to find someone
who can keep up with you.
That's going to be a big part.
Yup.
For sure.
One hundred percent in love that it has
to.
But is that going to be exact?
I mean I've dated guys that are very
high functioning Alpha type a's and it
was exhausting.
Well that doesn't necessarily have to be
exhausting.
You just have to find someone who's
known knows that look,
you can have a car that's 600 horsepower
and not know what the fuck to do with
it.
And you're going sideways around every
corner just because you have all that
power and all that energy.
It doesn't mean you're utilizing it
correctly.
Or You could have a car that has 600
horsepower and you take every corner
perfectly and you know when it hit the
gas and it's always there when you need
it,
but you don't use it.
Yeah.
Just chill.
Do you talk about this?
I don't know.
I figured it out.
How did you know that you were like,
I'm gonna commit to this person?
No.
Oh Shit.
Or like any day now.
Actually,
no,
I just got to be.
You have to feel,
feel safe with the person,
feel calm when the person enjoy being
around them,
you know?
And there the other thing is a person
like you or me or anyways,
so you have a lot of options.
That's an issue too because if you don't
have any,
if you live in a small town,
it's only a few people.
You find someone quickly,
musical chairs.
No,
but
you have a lot of options.
You're like,
well this guy is just not quite doing
the farming.
Let me just fucking go test the waters.
And then you're out
there checking your dating app and who.
So you throw your phone in your home.
It's a full time job.
Also like I see,
you know,
and this is a generalization,
but a lot of people that I know that
are,
you know,
getting the most of being the most
effective in life do have calm,
predictable home lives or healthy.
If you were going out every night to
Winston's,
what's Wednesday?
I don't know.
It's like a glove in La at Winston.
This.
No,
whatever.
If you were going to Maggio is little
Italy at the grove every night trying to
pick up girl,
you would have no time to build an
empire.
There is no time to work.
It's a full time job.
Well,
that's a debt is a real issue with
trying to settle.
I'm in the market to compromise.
Well then you'll probably find someone
if you're willing to compromise,
but are you really willing to compromise
or you just saying that right now,
once there's a guy there and he's flawed
and you think about guys that you used
to date that weren't flawed.
Yeah,
but I'm trying to not view objectify
people that way.
It's like I'm flawed too.
Like where do I get off?
We're all flawed for sure.
I also think like there's this and
there's this and I don't know if it's
that feminism,
like we can leave that out of it,
but there's this new trend where women,
uh,
my girlfriend's,
a lot of them who are like,
I deserve better than this.
And I'm like,
no,
you don't.
You're a b minus,
you deserve a b minus.
For me,
when I'm like,
I deserve this and this.
I'm like,
no,
I don't like,
I deserve someone who's kind of a mess.
I think you could certainly get lucky.
I think I definitely got lucky with my
wife.
She's a really nice person.
She's smart,
she's calm,
she's very patient.
Must be easy to get along with.
I think for me,
and this is the first time I've thought
this way,
it's maybe not about who that person is.
It's about who I am with that person.
That's the everything.
That's everything because you who you
are like we were talking about this
before,
if you're around people that are
negative,
shit bleeds off into your brain and when
you're around people that are nice,
you feel nicer.
Who are you around?
You're like,
you're calm and you're Scott.
I tried to be this guy all the time,
you know?
For the most part I am.
I just don't want to go home and work
though some hammered or you drink
definitely drink or you to do like what?
Like like I don't want to guess.
I mean I've been drunk a bunch of times
on podcasts,
just trying to make it more fun.
Oh,
I respect.
I listen to them.
You could do that.
Let's do that one will get hammered.
High Five.
Let's do that.
That'd be fun to Uber Home.
This is what happens when we're sober.
We're just watching zip pop,
popping years that we're just going to
watch animal attacks.
We're gonna Watch all those guys in
China while I was in China where they
keep sneaking those animal enclosures.
Wait,
did joe let Whitney pop his backset
found on a podcast?
We get ingrown hairs or something.
Friends,
when I see x,
I'm like,
can I get it?
Can I get it?
They're like,
we're not dating anymore.
You don't get to do that.
It's grooming.
Were monkeys were monkeys with guns?
We're just monkeys.
We talked about this last time that um,
uh,
a Bonobo apes and humans have more
similar DNA than African elephants in
Indian elephants.
No Apes.
It's really fascinating.
They're the,
they have one restriction sexually the
mother won't have sex with the sun.
That's it.
Women who have sex with women.
Men have sex with men.
That's like a good genetic sort of
survival instinct because doesn't that
incest is breeds with the dad fucks his
daughters.
Oh,
that's not fair.
Nope.
Rude.
That like a freaking equality.
It is A.
I might not be pronouncing this right.
A gyn ocracy like apparently they call
it a Gyn ocracy because they use their
vaginas to get what they want is power.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
I mean some people humans do that.
It is fascinating that they're the least
violent champion the month that has the
most sex.
Oh yeah.
By far.
Well,
yeah.
I mean that's another way to get your
aggression out.
That's been sort of our theme today.
Well,
I've been thinking about this whole lot
lately when I examine human culture and
civilization and all the fucking
atrocities that we commit on a daily
basis.
And then I look back at,
you know,
I was reading this piece about ancient
man and you know,
the trials and tribulations,
neanderthals and Homo sapiens how to
deal with.
And I was thinking what is the
difference between Neanderthal in Cro
Magnon?
Good question.
I always get this wrong.
Cro-Magnon is the early version of us.
The tall is a different different breed
of human neanderthal.
We're humans,
right?
I conflate them all the time and I.
Okay,
now I understand that.
I think cro magnon is not us though.
It's not like it's not homo sapiens.
I don't think.
I always like Australia.
Pythagoreous I think was the first
human,
the first human like creature honor to
be the dumbest person on your podcast.
I don't think.
You definitely never done clearly.
You've never met Brian Red band
skeleton.
Say Brian Gallon.
They had a unliked neanderthals,
cro,
magnon and not a separate species.
In fact,
they're the earliest known European
example of our species living between
$35,000
and 10,000
years ago.
That's what's so fucked up.
Ten thousand years ago is nothing.
Nothing.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a second.
And then actually modern in every
anatomical way.
Huh?
You guys learned something in a.
that's nuts.
10,000
years is so recent.
And here's the craziest thing.
They only existed 175,000
years ago.
The emerged.
So 175,000
years ago,
humans emerged.
So before 175,000
years ago,
which is a blink in time roughly.
They don't really know the,
you know,
the,
the changes there,
their estimate changes based on fossil
evidence.
But that's so recent.
Recently,
what I was thinking is when we're
looking at are our issues,
you know,
dating and love and friendship and
creativity
and ambition,
all these weird issues that human beings
have today in this
and weirdly luxurious world problems
left and right.
That's like 100 years old.
Yeah.
What
is the future going to be like?
Like what?
What is a modern human in the year 20
slash 75
going to be Vr,
right?
I mean,
aren't we all just going to be in our
virtual reality machines just
masturbating and.
Well,
we might be the last people to touch our
genitals.
Probably this will be the last pussy
spanking generation.
The last,
maybe the last few.
Maybe sex will be fake.
I mean there was a book called,
I'm sorry to circle back to porn again,
but there's a book called porn nation
and in it there was a statistic that
said 80 percent of kids under 18 boys
would rather watch porn than have sex
with an actual woman.
Wrong fact check it.
Focus groups,
it's probably a very specific group of
people who would agree to be interviewed
about whatever the same assholes.
I think women have to masturbate in tubs
only.
No Kid.
So,
but I mean who knows?
I mean you could fake fake boobs,
fake news.
Uh,
you could probably prefer because you're
in control of it.
If you have a vr woman who's going to do
whatever you want,
you don't have to deal with her
afterwards and like talk about like what
are we?
But that's half the thrill you have to.
But you didn't grow up on fake women and
Anna May.
Wow.
Jerking off to cartoons.
You don't understand.
Like we watched Saturday morning
cartoons.
They are jerking off to animate and
white men.
Oh God.
So why,
how many,
how many of them?
Most of them are jerking.
Will you look up in an animated like how
many people are poor?
I would say it's a very small number by
the way.
A lot of the women in real porn or more
lifeless than the animated important,
but they're weird now because it
couldn't fake ass as well.
It's like John beaudry yards,
like theory of like simulacrum about
like how we prefer this simulation of
something to the original of something
when we can actually control it.
I think Andy Warhol was onto that as
well,
but.
Well isn't it bizarre that some men
prefer fake boobs?
Like they get.
Why?
Donald?
Getting off to anime porn is shorthand
for supporting Donald Trump connection.
Lorin griset.
How to say the name or Sydney or Sydney.
Oh,
this just happened to pop up,
but what a bizarre fucking title.
Okay.
Let's.
Let's see what she has to say.
God Damn it.
Forbes continue to push forward.
Yeah,
it's hilarious.
On Tuesday evening,
gop consultant Rick Wilson made twitter,
but to do waves with.
Look at that.
They have the fucking stock of twitter,
right?
They're single men plus zero,
50 percent,
zero point 50 percent in that hilarious.
They showed twitter and then they have
people reading Forbes.
What we'll just stock at
the stock number right next to the
audience.
So weird waves with his claim that
donald trump's supporters are mostly
single men who masturbate to way.
He's at glp consultant too.
I think they're right with this
unintentionally incendiary statement
that Wilson says he made directly to
troll trump's followers.
February's trolling everybody.
First of all,
as any enemy fan will let you know.
It's called,
um,
clears throat.
Hentai a specific genre of x ray to
Japanese animated cartoons.
But what's interesting is that in order
to intentionally make people angry,
Wilson targeted anime Geeks as his
insults.
Okay.
It's tweet.
Don't upset them.
Yeah.
They'll,
they'll find you reply you.
I don't know.
I can't,
I can compete with I,
I feel strongly that's.
I'm like,
okay,
I can compete with the girl I've seen.
I can't compete with cartoons.
Yeah.
That cellulite,
it's,
I really don't want to have stats on how
many people,
how one website is convincing people to
pay for cartoon porn.
If you're paying for cartoon port,
just watch Jessica Rabbit.
Whoa.
Hold on a second.
Among 18 to 34 year old viewers,
cartoon and hand tie are the 13th and
17th most popular porn searches.
And millennials are 131 percent more
likely to search for anime than older
browsers.
This is what I'm saying.
Whoa.
You just blew my mind.
So can we see what the other 12 porn
categories are?
Above Sol gagging,
gagging while getting choked,
gagging,
pregnant bench gagging,
Gangbang,
gang.
Oh,
here we go.
Number one with the fucking bullet,
lesbian and then teen,
and then let's not brushed past team.
That's of awful.
That's horrifying.
Your monsters.
I'd rather you watch anime.
A step.
Mom is MILF.
Wait,
whoa.
And then squirt.
People are into peeing.
People are into square.
They liked the squirt.
I think it's anything other than pain.
And then mom was pulling.
It's a mixture.
Well,
I am interested in really coming out of
your pussy.
It's p circle.
We're going to circle back and then when
scientists analyze it,
they go,
well,
it's not all p were in circle back.
We're going to circle back to that.
Uh,
so it's interesting to me that step mom
is above MILF.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
I want,
I don't want it.
I want a mom.
I don't want to be.
You want to fuck your dad's wife.
That's what it is.
That is that a weird Freudian penis
envy.
Envy thing,
number one.
Number one,
at the bottom,
rather the least.
His public public is the least search.
Anal is above.
Anal is shockingly low.
I know Ebony Ebony is above black,
which I think is the district.
I'm so educated people.
Oh wait,
wait.
No one is a million.
What?
Wait,
why is.
Why is Japanese and Asian?
I know why they're different.
Kind of.
But do you see how they're different
categories?
Asians way down
low people are way more into Japanese
and they are specifically Japanese.
Asian.
You get like Vietnamese,
Thai and people are like,
nope.
Nope,
nope,
nope.
Don't draw the line.
I want to a girl with the Komono.
Yeah.
Geisha girl.
Oh,
interesting.
So it's like a power thing.
Yeah,
but I think anything I say here is going
to be misconstrued as not racist.
Don't be worried about that.
This is the age we live in.
Okay.
At what is the difference where you have
an even black.
I'm so sorry.
There is no difference.
One of them has said by people with
education.
Got It.
And the other one is someone who just
wants to get on a mess,
but I'd imagine what's under those one's
going to be classier than the other.
Maybe there's something socio lineals
search term differences.
Look at this.
Cosplay.
It's cosplay.
Sorry.
I don't know.
Search coming or shitting costumes.
Shit.
Why would you.
Why would you think cosplay as toilet?
I don't know,
but I said it so nonchalantly put job.
Look at that.
What is the foot fetish thing?
Can you know?
I guess it's like something happening
when you were young.
Oh,
like some sort of a.
isn't that called Texas?
Oh,
my thing is called imprinting sexual
imprinting.
That Yoga.
Let me see.
Yoga is in there right below the yoga
balls and porn these days.
I see a lot of sex on yoga balls.
I do not feel sexy,
but Jim is above yoga,
which is interesting.
More fit.
More people couldn't relate.
Like girl doing squats.
What if she just wanted to fuck right
now,
that duke people.
I'm watching.
What's a pov now that I heard that porn
star in La fitness.
I get the gym porn.
What is emo?
Goth girls to Morrissey really?
Tattoos now.
I mean that's part of suicide girl type
girl.
Suicide girl.
Emo.
No.
Know what it is.
Yeah,
sure.
I mean that's what they are.
Why they call it emo though.
Suicide girl generality.
I would think.
Emo.
A bunch of marches.
Put suicide on here.
Then you're looking for suicide port and
that's a way different thing than corn.
That's just a crime.
What's that guy who committed suicide?
Elliot something or another.
What?
Elliot Smith is that his name?
Duncan told me to listen to them.
I listened to him like,
Duncan,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
It was like super depressing music and
like,
no wonder this guy stabbed himself.
Wait,
can you walk me through this?
So what does dogging does?
Dogging or walking,
but says dogging dogging.
What the fuck is that?
Long nipples is at the very bottom.
Granny is well above long nipples.
Wait,
so synonymous Harry smoking with
smoking.
Where does that wife shockingly low.
Why is it negative?
Does this mean it's become less popular?
This one is actually a comparing.
Millennials searches to people older
than them.
This is millennials.
Are more into all this,
but this stuff is all new.
Millennials never probably had the
opportunity to see granny,
granny porn.
That's more prevalent now than ever
before.
What if you were a grant?
What if you were 80 doing porn?
What does that.
What is that?
That's a pitch that.
No,
she's going to die.
Just wants a rod up boat right into the
rocks.
Hit the throttle.
She's bobbing across the top of the
ocean.
She sees the rocks.
She doesn't let up at all,
which isn't even close her eyes.
This is upsetting.
Go back up.
Stop scrolling so much for them.
No two categories.
Kim Kim.
Kim Kardashian is the most popular porn
star.
Searched by millennials.
Porn Star.
She's got a porn tape.
Oh,
that's amazing.
I know the rest of the Khalifa.
Who's like a,
uh,
she's A.
I don't.
No nothing.
Lisa Ann,
who's deep in her forties,
I believe her victory.
Interesting.
I don't know any of these people.
Sasha Gray.
I feel like she.
She's fallen off the.
I don't think she doesn't anymore.
She something.
She retired her vagina.
Throw in the towel.
Yeah.
You mean it's like a fighter,
they get enough head shots and I'm like,
I gotta I gotTa step away.
I said enough concussions in the back
row.
I don't know.
I mean I know I met like I did a job
that does sound crazy,
so I hired Jenna Jamison to do something
in a pilot that I did and I met her
fiance and she was actually really cool.
Like I like that the all the weird,
like recently her twitter feed has
revealed something else,
but when I met her she seemed quite
normal,
whatever that even means and her sober
now,
her guy had not,
didn't know she was Jenna Jamison for
like a couple months.
I do not believe it.
I know her.
She's a very nice person.
I'd rather not comment on her personal
lifestyle.
I don't really know.
I support anyone who's trying to escape
that world.
I'm just wondering if.
Because I also with guys that I date,
like I never want them to see my
standup.
Do you think that.
How many guys have you dated?
Were you were on a date with them for
awhile before they figured out that you
were a famous comedian?
I mean,
since I've done standup,
I don't.
Never.
Yeah,
maybe.
No,
it was always the elephant in the room.
Well,
it's always like,
have you seen my specialist?
Have you not?
And someone I'm seeing now,
I was like,
could you not if you watch them,
just just so that you have an
opportunity to just get to know me first
before you hear me talking about for 40
minutes.
He was like,
I'd rather not actually.
And I'm like,
cool.
Whereas some guys,
look what's your specialists note book
and squirting.
And I'm like,
okay,
it's,
I don't want.
I don't want the guys I date to see me
that way.
So I would.
I'm just,
I'm just codependently worried about
Sasha grace future.
Wow.
She seems like a very smart person.
Really?
Yeah.
A buddy of mine,
you still work for the flashlight and
he'd met her and she reads books a lot
and she's very smart.
Just freak.
She did a whole article about that,
like she had done some mainstream movie,
the girlfriend experience or something.
Yep.
That's right.
Yeah.
And you know,
apparently she did some interview about
it.
She was like,
I'm just sort of embracing my inner
slut.
She's like,
I like it.
Like,
how come like guys are allowed to do
that.
I have parents and I have,
I don't put it on.
Maybe that's the thing.
Maybe it's the Paris.
Anything different there or maybe you
have,
you don't have parents,
you want to punish you or maybe some,
some women have parents that they want
to punish,
want their dad who doesn't talk to them
ever to see this and realize how bad he
fucked up.
Yeah.
Oh,
interesting.
It could be an inactive aggression.
I mean,
there's a lot of people that I would
like to,
uh,
punished,
get revenge on and I still don't have
sex on camera and upload it to Vimeo.
Well,
because that's also self punishment in
some ways.
You're setting yourself up to massive
amounts of.
Yes,
I like,
I was,
I went just for no good reason.
I went to Ronda Rousey's instagram page
other day because she showed up in my
feed.
I went to her page and I looked at some
of the comments on some of her pictures
in the Holy Shit.
Other monsters out there about sexual
stuff?
No,
I mean there's.
I'm sure there's some of it was sexual.
What?
I just thought it was just mean like you
open yourself up to just being fucking
people.
I mean she,
I don't know,
like she I'm sure is doesn't look at
that or something,
but whenever I look at it,
I'm out for a couple days.
I'm,
I can't look at it.
Yeah.
Apparently they have to keep Donald
Trump away from twitter and from
instagram and the television because
there was some thing that we're talking
about some,
some campaign aid that was like,
you know,
we,
we have to keep him away.
You got to keep them distracted.
You've got to keep them away from the
television because he becomes fixated
and just wants to talk about like
someone who's doing a Saturday night
live sketch about them.
Well,
there's,
I mean there's,
look,
I don't know enough about politics to
really talk about it and it really
doesn't matter what,
who you are interested,
not,
but like he shows the signs of a
clinical narcissist and whether that's
good or bad.
Maybe presidents should be narcissists,
maybe athletes.
I don't know where that benefits you.
I'm sure there are careers where it
does,
but narcissists have that kind of
addiction theory is scary for a leader.
It makes sense for an artist or for an
athlete that you have to have some sort
of narcissism to become j.
Lo to.
I'm just say I'm the best in the world
to be a diva or to be a whatever the
fuck you are.
But yeah,
it becomes a real scary thing when it's
like.
I remember,
um,
when he was talking about Kanye West,
when Kanye West did that thing in front
of this giant concert and he said,
I didn't vote,
that if I did vote I would vote.
He said,
I vote on trump,
which just didn't seem like it doesn't
even have a vote on trump.
Like,
what?
Thank God you don't vote.
But helping.
Well it is interesting,
like I was gonna say is he did this
thing where he's talking about it in
front of this gigantic group of people
where he's talking about he loves trump.
He loves.
I love Kanye because Kanye loves trump
and he was talking about himself in
third person.
It was so disturbing and it's like this
is such a weird way of addressing that
instead of saying in a gracious way.
That was very kind of him.
I appreciate him.
He's a brilliant artist and it's very
nice to have a support.
Thank you.
Kanye.
Instead of just saying that he loves
trump.
Well he loved what I love Kanye because
Kanye live.
Trump,
he loves trump.
Like he kept saying it and repeating.
It broke like an Asian person speaking
broken English.
He's also a 70 year old grandpa who's
out there working 150 hours a day and
he's probably ragged.
But your thing about impulse control,
it's like if you can't go,
you're not going to send that.
I'm going to put a pin in that and spend
some time critical thinking before I
sort of act.
But this is also a man who did you hear
what he said?
Um,
he was like,
you know,
I,
I can see things from every angle.
I'm not doing impressions.
Uh,
I can see things from every angle
probably better than anyone.
Yeah.
Well,
he always does.
Anyone you know.
But I'm fascinated by how much a mental
illness can help you.
And then when it starts to backfire on
you,
you know,
it's obviously worked pretty well on
some level.
Well,
what's going on now is his mental state
or his,
the way he behaves,
his personality is being examined by the
brightest minds in the world in a very
brutal about us.
Other people that are the dumbest
idiots.
So let's talk about comics and gagging
for watching,
zip popping,
but he's,
you know,
he's under this.
There's a level of scrutiny that you get
if you're a rapper like Kanye west or a
fighter like Rhonda Rousey.
And then there's this whole nother level
when you want to be the center of the
entire nuclear armament for the United
States of America.
You want to be the commander in chief
for the greatest country.
The world has ever known and that's what
he's.
He's done.
He's,
and I don't think it's good.
I don't know how it's was talking about
this and I think Howard knows him pretty
well.
I think it was very astute what he was
saying.
It's like it's not good for him.
Like mentally,
it's like the guy wants to be loved and
you're just not going to be loved in
that job.
Nobody.
Nobody gets loved.
Yeah,
you did it to get love and you're
getting the massive amount of hate come
at you.
But he is getting love from a specific
area.
People.
I mean I'm again fascinated by the
primal element of it,
of how we,
you know,
the people are who are responding well
to what he's doing are responding to
Alpha and we have a,
I think reptilian attraction to Alpha
males.
I mean,
I'll say it when I was watching him in
early,
early on and that in the early debates
when there was like six candidates on
stage,
as much as.
I mean I did his
roast,
I met him.
He was gross to me.
Like,
yeah,
oh he's,
he's,
he's the guy who puts his hand on your
lower back when he talks to you for no
reason at all.
Like it was just like,
you know,
but he's,
he's a car.
Was a cartoon character of Donald Trump.
I mean,
it's like he's the earth dots version of
Donald Trump.
It's so surreal at this point.
Uh,
but I saw him sort of knowing all of his
shortcomings this before anyone actually
thought he would become president.
He,
I'm not that the other candidates didn't
have shortcomings,
but he said to all of the people,
he pointed them all out and he was like,
you've asked me for money,
you've asked me for money.
You Bet.
And it was so ballsy and courageous.
And I was like,
my primal brain was like,
if there's an earthquake,
I'm,
I'm going with that guy.
I think we're all in such a survivalist
mindset with what's happened with the
economy and people are struggling for.
I get it,
you know?
And I was like,
Yep,
that guy's the most fearless
motherfucker have the budge.
Everybody is so calculated and scared
and reserved.
They weren't prepared for that.
There's,
I don't think politics in general was
prepared for someone with that mindset.
Someone who can rebound from that,
grab the pussy thing and be like,
it was locker room talk.
He didn't care.
If he apologized,
we would have been pissed.
I mean,
I mean at least to support this would've
been pissed.
He didn't apologize.
So yeah,
I said it.
There's something in our primal brains
that's like,
yes,
that guy can protect me when shit goes
down.
Well there's also like people are tired
of really ultra left wing nanny state
type people to want to tell you what you
can say and what you can say to behave
and totally trigger word
and you're so good at like you're not
contributing to this problem.
You're part of this solution of.
I think there's also like we were
talking about earlier with Catholic
schools in the pendulum swinging of this
like hyper political correctness and
then just this reaction of like,
this motherfucker does not care.
He's saying Muslims are bad and they're
raped,
but like he's saying what our crazy
uncle says at dinner every night,
you know,
and like there's just something brave
about it that's attractive to people.
I think there is hope that someone is
going to recognize the positive elements
of that kind of not total disregard for
the way people view him,
but,
but having the confidence to be yourself
and then meeting much closer to the
middle in terms of being compassionate
and kind and being open minded and
instead of apologetic and weekend scare.
Exactly.
Thank you.
Can Be both.
You know,
and the other part of the Democratic
Party is showing a,
a,
a lack of people who are unapologetic
fearless and um,
have a plum.
Yeah.
This also,
there's,
it's interesting watching people that
he's trying to assign a different
cabinet positions backing out.
They're like,
nope,
sorry.
No amount of money can deal with the
hate frats and the pussy hats out my
front door.
It's so detrimental to your career.
And if they think the boat is sinking,
like,
oh,
this might make it the ocean.
But
I could also just.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a fascinating time,
I think,
to explore the kind of things that you
explore in your show,
which is human nature and our primordial
instincts because this is,
has been,
I think,
the most tribal primal thing I've,
I've witnessed in my lifetime.
I've never seen so much separation
between the left and the right and the,
the anger and fury that's going on
today.
A great article in,
I think it was scientific American.
I think about when people are wrong
about something because here's the other
thing,
like even if you voted for trump and he
promised you,
you know,
manufacturing jobs will come back,
which is kind of impossible given modern
technology.
He promised something that is sorta like
technologically not a feasible.
But um,
even if,
if when you voted for him,
you were right to,
he was going to give you.
He said Isis in 30 days,
it's been more than 30 days,
hasn't done.
You know,
when people say,
you know,
I was wrong,
that guy fucking lied to me.
It's so hard for us to do that because
of our ego.
And there was an article in scientific
American help people in Grand,
I'm sure this study was skewed and it's
a specific group of people that sign up
for a study,
but that when someone was wrong,
when someone told them they were wrong,
it made them believe their point even
more.
I don't know,
there's the article I'll send,
I'll send it to you or are they doubled
down?
But if you say to them,
uh,
and I think that it's the CIA that uses
this as a form of questioning is that
you first have to legitimize their
position before you suggest that there
might be something flawed about it.
So you go like,
you know,
I totally understand that you would
think that,
you know,
the earth is flat.
I can see why you would thought that.
I mean,
you grew up here.
Of course you thought that if you
empathize with them first and then say,
know,
but turns out it's round.
They'll more,
they're more likely to come around.
But if you just say,
hey,
you know,
that's fucking wrong.
And if you show them proof,
they doubled down even further on there.
What's the worst thing you say to
someone's upset?
Calm down.
Relax.
They just get fucking furious.
Yeah,
it's a non.
It's a non respecting thing.
You're not respecting the person's state
of mind.
You're not,
you're not objectively stepping back and
looking,
how does this person really feel right
now and what's the best one?
You're a demoralizing and what we're all
doing is demoralizing each other,
but going,
you're fucking wrong.
You're stupid.
And something that was interesting just
from an I know that I am in Hollywood
and I don't know anything about
politics.
I know you don't have to tweet it.
I know,
but one thing I do know is that,
um,
and I was sort of fascinated by the
comedians role in,
in this election because as the dino
news fails us in a lot of ways,
a comedians sometimes tend to sort of
show up and,
and,
and tell the truth.
But I'm in every movie.
The underdog always has to win and
right.
It's just really fucking baseball,
I'm sure.
What is the field of dreams?
Rocky?
Exactly.
So I was like,
everybody beating up on him and you're
just making him the underdog and
underdogs always have to win.
It's just like some weird human nature,
destiny.
Also the president,
like you can't really be the underdog
and be the Kenya anything.
He was an underdog.
I think during the election we were
beating up on him and I think we were
going q stupid,
you're dumb,
you're not qualified.
And then everyone was like,
oh,
we gotta fucking root for that guy
because we were,
you know,
I just going to take the establishment
down.
But meanwhile he's bringing in all these
fucking bank.
Yeah.
And people tweeting about them just gave
them hundreds of millions of dollars of
free press.
It was just sort of interesting how we
sort of hoodwinked ourselves and just
tweeting about them.
The things that he said were the things
that CNN decided they were going to
cover and now he won't let CNN into the
press or the New York Times wouldn't let
the New York Times the press gaggle.
But he let info wars and all these other
weird websites.
And I mean it's,
it's very,
it's very odd.
It's like that's unprecedented that
he's,
he's limiting access to the press.
I mean he filed for reelection five
hours after he won.
I mean this guy is like,
you know,
and there's something amazing about it,
like he has figured out a way to
hypnotize a nation or a world.
I mean there's something just so primal
at play.
The juke in the system the same way he's
choked the system with taxes and with,
you know,
with the filing for bankruptcy were
mostly designed to follow rules and to
comply with what is socially acceptable.
Right.
That's like how we get dopamine.
It's like just fit in,
be part of the pack.
That's how you stay safe.
And he is not one of those people and
it's just pretty fascinating what.
No,
not by any stretch of the imagination.
It's,
it's unprecedented that this person,
that the lies all the time.
That's logically,
pathologically.
Yeah.
But you.
But,
but these getting called on it though,
which is weird to see that the reporter
who said he said to him,
you said that you won by the largest
margin.
It was someone told me that he said,
well,
he said,
it was amongst Republicans,
and then he said no,
because George h dot w dot Bush had a
larger electoral college victory.
Like,
well what?
They told him,
what I've been told,
but there's also within,
this is sort of back to the horse thing,
like it doesn't matter what you say,
it matters how you say it.
Right,
and do people care if they're being lied
to,
if they're being lied to in an
authoritative way with someone who seems
very confident,
like they know what they're fucking
doing,
what's going to chip away at them
though?
This is what I really believe that all
these times where he's being checked,
this is the reason why you won't go to
the White House press correspondents'
dinner.
Like that's weird saying,
well this is member.
When he wouldn't go on the debates,
he wouldn't go on CNN.
He,
this happened.
This has been going on where he just
refuses to be president.
I don't Hae,
hasn't not even moved in and he's been
golfing most of his presidency and it's
caused us money.
No,
he sends his kids on these business
trips to go set up hotels and the
countries that don't have to protect
this kid.
I can't tell if people care,
but little known yet.
It's only been.
It's only been 30 something days.
How long has he been in the White House?
January.
Yeah,
so he's been in the White House a little
over a month.
Yeah,
and most people are just living their
lives and they're busy and they're busy
and they just don't even have time while
for that information to trickle
into the entire country.
Like it's getting into some people.
There's people that are furious.
There's,
you know,
there's New York Times writers who are
writing on on a daily basis and there's
all these different authors.
I mean I just think there's something to
be said for and I'm working on this in
my life to be able to be like,
I was wrong.
You got me good,
you hoodwinked me and I'm wrong.
And now what do you think that people
are going to do that though?
Because that's,
that's acquiescing to the left or just
act.
I mean,
or just being sane going like I was,
I was bamboozled and,
but being seen as not,
that doesn't work when you have these
party politics when you're tribal,
tribal,
so team oriented.
I mean it's just something that's
ingrained in us to have an enemy,
an enemy to fight with and then it
becomes all about our projections.
I mean,
it's really been hard because I'm trying
to sort of like,
especially going on stage,
like I had a riot breakout and Napa
people started fighting in a crowd.
What were you talking about?
And they write it.
This was before the election and I
really started out with being like,
you know,
what,
politics is not my thing.
There's people who are much better at it
and I let them do it.
If you want to talk about squirting,
you come to me.
But like I know my,
I stay in my lane and.
But this felt like something that was
just,
you know,
beyond,
uh,
something that was,
it almost feels weird to ignore it on
stage.
It's like the elephant linear.
And so I was talking about it at night.
I was like,
look,
I'm not saying who I think should win.
I think both candidates have flaws.
I think there's one that's less flawed,
but whatever.
And I said something about,
you know,
if bill is in the White House because
it'd be interested.
First female president was just
something about like,
what happens with the first female
president now I think that there should
be a rule saying that the first female
male can cheat.
So because the woman doesn't have,
she doesn't have time to fuck him,
like she doesn't have time and this
woman yelled out.
She was like,
how dare you talk about Hillary?
Uh,
you know,
this is one of the most conservative
areas in the country.
You need to know your audience.
This lady said that she was in the
second row.
She was with me the entire time.
Turns on me and I was like,
and I just know your audience like I now
I realized wrongly was like,
oh no,
you need to know your comedian.
I don't give a shit.
And that was a bad.
Well I,
well I,
I thought so.
But then the audience all went after her
and then her,
she had like a bunch of people with her
and it was just turned into like a
Malay.
Like it was awesome.
It was,
you would have loved it.
I was here in Napa.
They're probably drunk as shit faced.
I was so scared and because it was not,
no one was tractable.
It wasn't like,
oh,
the bodyguard,
it was like everybody was getting up and
fighting with everybody.
And so,
uh,
I hadn't really talked about on stage,
but it just,
so it's,
it's just so deep.
It's so visceral with people.
It's like we're in war.
I mean this country's in a psychological
war,
psychological,
civil war and I can't and you can't
bring it up with anybody.
It just is like,
I feel like I'm walking on eggshells
around it and this is the first time I
think I've ever even talked about.
I don't even tweet about it.
I just kind of like,
um,
how did the show end?
Fire quickly earthquake.
I got my check and it cleared.
Um,
but no,
they had to be like 16 people had to be
removed when the show went on and I
ended up,
I mean for me,
like if someone tells me I just had to,
so I had to go harder at the political
thing and it was,
but it's kind of thing where I thrive
and adrenaline and conflict.
I was just like,
bitches,
this is how I grew up.
Like don't,
don't clucking I'm looking for an excuse
to fight people,
like don't do this,
don't you think you also have being fun,
starting out and doing a lot of work
rather at the comedy store,
like fucking original room comic,
like you fucked with the wrong monster
with the idea she could say know your
audience the most conservative place in
the like she was like,
no,
you're like,
cater your material to us.
Which was just so yeah,
she was one of those.
I mean it was really demeaning and it
was really.
And I think I also was like got very
deeply insulted.
Like,
you know,
I was a slot machine that are like a
jukebox where she puts money in and I'm
just supposed to do what she wants me to
do and I was like,
comedians were the only ones left who
are taking risks and saying shit that no
one else will say like,
how dare you.
Like I felt like it was an attack on
free speech in general.
Like,
well people have their ideas of what
you're supposed to do,
you know,
this is how you're supposed to behave if
you're this,
this is how you're supposed to have a
bedside manner.
If you're a doctor,
if you're a comedian,
you know you have to tailor your jokes.
I think it's,
I think it's like if you're.
I mean,
I know for,
I mean I'm in comedy,
so I think if a comedian doesn't make
you a little uncomfortable at some
point,
we're kind of not doing our job.
You know?
I always think it's hilarious and
someone tells you not to talk about
something.
Like someone tells you next subject.
Have you ever had someone to yell out
next subject?
Oh my gosh.
I've had some pretty,
well I've had sometimes I'm Kevin
Christie,
a pointed out to me one time that I'm
about to open for me a long time,
about 45 minutes into my set,
someone always turns on me.
It's usually a man who just has had a
drink and I've turned.
I turned into their wife,
like a woman talking to a microphone at
you for that long.
I will become your mother or your ex
wife,
the girl who didn't fucking you in high
school.
Like there's some booze.
The booze.
Like I just,
I like.
And one time we were in the Hoya,
which you know,
is the most just chaotic group of sort
of drunk people.
Xanax and yeah.
And I did this joke about like how guys
ages ago.
Um,
they,
uh,
um,
they have,
every guy is like a jar of coins in
their house somewhere,
like,
like pennies,
like it's like a,
it's like a or like a bowl of coins and
uh,
everyone's laughing and blah blah.
And this guy just snaps at me.
He had been in the front row laughing
the entire time and he was just like,
that's so we can pay for a year and a
very quickly I realized
that I had transmogrified into someone
and uh,
so it's triggering,
I mean going into see comedy can be
triggering.
I think it should be.
That's heavy.
Yeah,
it should be.
Obviously he went to sort of a different
place,
but it's,
yeah,
we basically trigger drunk people for a
living that just want to be heard.
You have with that.
So,
so innocuous.
Like why would anybody be upset the have
a jar of coins.
I mean it's kind of funny because a lot
of guys do.
You have a jar and they chuck coins in
it and then they eventually bring it to
the bank.
Go do something with this.
Yeah.
It was just like a shitty observational
jokes from six years ago,
you know.
But I get a lot of times I'm the most
annoying thing is actually just when
people are like so true.
Like just to,
oh I.
for me,
that compliments the backhanded
compliments after the show are always
the worst.
Like you're really funny for them or
like,
um,
I don't care what anyone says.
You're hilarious.
It's stuff like that,
hey,
don't my friend hates you.
But I think you're pretty good at
listening to them.
You're amazing.
You know,
just sort of like so many crazy people.
Thirty four.
I mean,
I get the craziest,
the craziest.
I mean,
you're so much prettier in person.
You're actually really pretty well.
That's actually nice.
It's a nice thing to say there's ever an
actual.
You're actually funny,
but that's night people.
Don't you think people would just
awkward?
Yes.
People get awkward.
Well,
I mean just like a guy trying to contact
you on a dating app.
They don't know how to like sort of
thinking.
I'm like,
no,
I have really low self esteem.
Next question.
Sitting in front of his phone,
trying to think of the right thing to
say,
what do you get people,
you must have people.
Because I think for comics,
like with celebrities who are like movie
stars,
people are like,
oh my God,
look down,
sorry,
that's emily blunt or whatever.
Right?
But with us,
they're like,
well,
it's like they think we're friends,
I find,
at least with me,
and uh,
people are super comfortable even more
so because of the podcast.
Yeah.
Do people just come up to you and
they're like,
hey man,
all the time I used to fight.
Yeah,
they just want to talk about all
constantly.
But the problem is sometimes I'm with my
kids and they just want to talk to me.
I'm like,
I can't talk to you.
What do you do?
You just say my family,
man.
I got to go,
hey man,
I got to ask you a question.
And they'll just go into these in depth
questions.
Like,
this is not happening.
I'm holding the hand of a six year old
right now and I'm on my way to do
something like this is not,
we're not going to sit here for half an
hour.
So you can talk about conor Mcgregor.
I mean,
it's a victory that you have created
such a group of people who are so into
it.
People come up to me about your,
uh,
your show Cordela,
at the gym,
but the gym.
So he's not talking about anal sex,
it's always.
Yeah.
They were like,
hey,
so I want to do is listen to you on
podcast.
People know so much about us that.
I mean it is tricky.
You.
I don't have a family,
but when I'm on dates and people are
like,
hey,
like how's your knee?
I'm like,
why?
You guys are always like,
who is this person?
I'm like,
I've never met this person.
What do they know more about you than I
do?
Well,
you get exposed in a weird way when you
do these long form conversations,
you can't forget it.
They can't hide.
I think that's who you are,
you know?
Yeah.
But it's like.
I definitely,
I mean I would imagine your listeners
know more about you than your wife does.
No,
she knows a lot of.
Really?
Yeah.
Does she listen?
She listens to me.
Hey girl.
She was,
she was listening to me and Ron White
and she just goes,
medians are so fucking weird.
She's like,
you guys are so honest.
Like you,
you,
you reveal shit that people would hide
until their death bed.
It's true.
And you guys are talking about it and
laugh and like Ron White was talking
about accidentally getting his dick
sucked by a bunch of guys.
I know,
I know.
It's really weird.
I listened to the episode.
I'm obsessed with Ron
in a million ways and I remember when he
said,
I just want respect from my peers.
And I was,
you know,
when we say things that no one else,
everyone thinks but no one else says,
I think it gives them grace to them.
So I think we sort of serve that
purpose.
Well,
I think that's got to be the worst thing
in the world is even being successful.
You know,
we can name a few people that are like
this,
but even being successful,
hated and despised by their peers.
It's hard.
It's like you don't,
you're a man without a country like
your,
your law.
The only people that understood me now,
hey,
that happened when I,
I got a TV show and all the,
the comedy store and the comments that
were like my family,
you know?
And then I got a show and then all of a
sudden everyone was mad at me and it was
the was around back then.
It was.
Yeah,
you were.
I'm trying to think when that was.
It was like five,
six years,
five years ago maybe.
It was the loneliest I've ever felt.
I was like,
the only people who understand me now
hate me.
So jealous and week.
It was awful.
Terrible.
I now know that it was just like them
being insecure and wanting,
you know.
And then everybody now has everyone's
got a show now
you know,
there's a lot of people that do have
this feeling that's never gonna happen
for them and there is no greater way to
ensure that it's never going to happen
for you then to have this feeling and
ride it out that it's never going to
happen for you.
It's like it's self fulfilling prophecy.
It's like the opposite of a placebo
effect
when it happens,
just you better be ready because it's
not gonna work.
If you're not ready.
Right.
And even if you're ready,
it might not work.
And if it doesn't work,
you can't think it's the end of time.
You gotta keep going,
you gotta keep set of Cameron.
But if you haven't healed the wound that
made you want the thing in the first
place,
the thing is not going to affect.
Absolutely.
I've gone into depth with comedians
about that because I think that's an
important thing to think.
We all started out from a fucked up
place.
Every comedian that's any good starts
out from a place of insecurity and
weakness,
and then somewhere along the line you've
got to become more secure and then it's
going to become about art.
It's got to become about creating
something that's good that people enjoy,
and then it's got to be about doing
something that people.
It's going to enhance people's
experience,
like they're going to go to see you,
and for an hour and a half that show
going to be so fun.
They're going to feel they're going to
literally feel better,
and it's got to be that healer.
Yeah,
and you're.
You're whatever.
Good feeling you get out of that.
Here's the sacrifice.
You're not gonna.
Enjoy it at all.
You're going to like,
I enjoy onstage killing,
but the creating in the process and the
going over the material and writing and
the chipping away at your fucking why is
it suck?
This topic sucks.
Should I abandon it or should I just
keep working at it
or it's working,
but it's fucking cheap.
Yeah.
And why the fuck are you guys laughing
at this?
This sucks.
I can't do that sort of self love and
hate yourself.
It's like it's like figuring out a way
to heal the wound that made you funny
but also stay funny.
So can you be healthy and funny?
I think that's my biggest question.
Can Struggle.
Yeah.
But it's not easy.
It's definitely a balancing act and
there's something that happens to
comedians when they become famous that
their main motivation was to get that
love and then they get it and then they
fucking suck.
Yeah.
Something happens that you stay
complacent.
You stop needing the approval or you
stop.
You know,
that's the perfectionism thing because
perfectionism is a lot of why I'm like,
so like my bar is so high for what to
say on stage and if I lower that bar as
it going to be less quality,
you know,
maintaining like you just need more
reinforcement personally in your
personal life to relax your
perfectionism in your career.
That's what I would think.
And I think you're right.
And I think what happened is aligning a
lot of people are like,
what do you mean you made it,
your everyone knows you and you're like,
well no,
that means I have to be even better.
Right?
Like the bar is now higher.
That's why you're scared to do a set at
the ice house.
Well,
I'm just kind of like,
we've talked about this.
I have a,
a like allergy to doing old material and
it makes me feel like a phony,
but it's good.
You should give it to some people.
I know.
Can you spit in their mouth?
That's the thing.
By the way,
there's a lot of open your mouth so I
can spit in it happening.
Do you guys think we like that?
I'm going to talk directly to camera.
Uh,
there's a lot of.
Let me spit in your mouth.
I'd rather you spend on my face.
Whoa.
Spitting in the mouth.
I was like,
then I have to like swap.
It's just like sexually spit.
Spit in your mouth.
Let me spit in your mouth.
Don't.
When did come in.
Your mouth becomes so boring.
Now there's the spinning in the mouth.
There's a lot of spitting.
I don't know a lot of spending.
A lot of them don't get it.
Degradation.
I don't get it.
I have heard though,
I heard from a guy,
nope.
I'm obsessed with what's the most
disrespectful thing a woman can do.
And I've had a couple guys say spit in
my face.
Just,
I mean in general,
like not sexual.
Oh,
like a woman who doesn't like you or if
you're like,
you know,
this guy I know his wife spit in his
face when they were in a fight and he
was like,
he's like,
it took every molecule in my body not
to,
not to work the back right here.
Just lose my mind.
And kill her.
That was his,
the most disrespectful because I'm
always interested in what,
you know,
people will stay with her.
Yeah.
She's married three.
Hilarious.
Yeah,
we've got to Barry,
he's in the military like he's all about
respect and whatever.
She's trying to push that,
like she can slap me all day long,
but spitting in my face that is the most
disrespectful thing you can do to a man.
So very dangerous thing when you get
physical with people.
Super Dangerous People's.
It's just,
it's very interesting.
I have a very high tolerance for
physical disrespect.
I mean just I,
and I was dealing with this with my
horse the other day.
She was disrespectful horses.
So you have to claim your space with a
horse and you have to draw a boundary if
you guys are going to like be around
because they can kill you.
And I don't really do it with eye.
You have to do it with dogs.
I made a mistake.
I mean,
yeah,
you just sort of claim your space and
they actually respect you more and like
you more when you have self respect and
you have sort of your boundary or else
they'll just walk all over you.
I mean,
it's metaphorical.
You don't seem to have this problem in
your life.
Um,
but with dogs,
you also,
for a dog to lay on top of you,
that's dominant.
We mistake it is like we're curdling but
they're actually in your space and
they're like,
oh,
well I own you now.
You know?
Yeah.
So a lot of times with my dogs,
especially since I get rescue dogs who
are unpredictable and pimples have a
very high arousal rate.
So I can't just let them lay on me all
night long and stuff.
I have to then go,
now you're off of me and you're my
bitch.
I'm not your bitch.
Because that could backfire later.
Jesus.
Yeah.
Dogs are so weird when you rescue them
because you just don't know what the
fuck they had to deal with.
Just don't know.
Yeah.
And I made some major mistakes of
mistaking physical proximity with like
trust.
And we'll be fine,
but when they're full grown.
Yeah,
because if they get possessive of you or
attached to you or um,
we sometimes think that's so cute,
but sometimes it's actually dominant.
Well,
it's also when you bring other people
into your life and then this dog decides
to other people stealing you from them
and they get aggressive towards the
other person,
it becomes an issue.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean it's really.
Dogs are just extensions of their own or
like you also have to let them know,
like I can talk to whoever the fuck I
want and you're not allowed to have a
problem with it.
So they're not allowed to get possessive
over you like that if you,
if you train them properly.
You know what's interesting?
The puppy that I got,
the Golden,
he,
we brought him home and he gives
everyone kisses.
Everyone kisses everyone because he's so
sweet.
But it gets to me and he wants to bite
my face.
He bites my face and he would play super
rough with me.
Like right away he was like nipping at
but not hard.
Like,
it wasn't hurting me,
but he's fun.
Like he's an animal.
Have you,
uh,
have you put his lip under his teeth?
You put your lip just show that they
learn how sharp their own teeth are.
Uh,
and yeah.
And then also bite them back to bite
them back.
Yeah.
I usually just put them on his back.
Yeah,
go ahead and cut the shit.
Hold them down with both of his,
you know,
I'm just trying to bite me when I'm
doing it because their mouth is their
hands.
Like he's not trying to hurt you.
No,
he's,
he's sweet.
But he thinks my six year old is a
puppy.
It's hilarious.
Like that's,
that's like a little puppy buddy.
Like he bites her clothes and stuff.
We have to keep them from doing that and
he's not being mean at all.
They don't care about clothes.
They're,
you know,
and they don't know until you tell them
what is wrong.
Like people,
people are so bad at training their
dogs.
It's shocking.
Like what I see like just in the streets
when I see someone with their dog,
like their dogs tugging and they're
like,
what are you doing?
I'm like,
Oh,
does your dog,
the one that speaks English and no
sarcasm.
Like what you would you stop that?
It's just like the way you're saying it
does not match what you're saying.
And that's not a command.
So I'm really into training dogs in a
very rigorous way too.
You also have to teach them my kids,
like,
you can't.
The dog doesn't understand his name
being used a bunch of different ways.
Like,
no,
no Marshall Marshall,
you've got to say no.
Children don't even understand that
sarcasm,
you know?
And uh,
yeah.
and people I think mistake and they
conflate discipline with being mean to
the dog or something.
It's just,
it's just not true.
It's discipline.
Discipline is so nice to a dog.
Um,
but uh,
yeah,
I mean it's just,
and,
but also when I see people,
I've seen some real disasters with
placing dogs in homes where people don't
train their kids how to deal with dogs.
I'm a dog.
Child's going to get their face bitten
off,
like I get so scared because people just
let their kid hit the dog in the face
and shake their face and I'm like,
you have to train your child.
Also.
Especially a dog dog,
there's a danger and bringing a dog
around children.
The first place kids are like another
dog and my dog's are giant.
My dog hurts me.
I've three.
They hurt me by accident all of the time
and I'm an adult.
Like I'll bend over to pick something up
and they'll come by and I.
Yes,
they don't mean to iron heads.
Yeah,
they are like my just blockheads.
And so,
um,
my big dog has a great Dane pitbull and
he just knocks me out the time.
So when kids come over,
they go in the crates,
they're not going to attack them.
But like,
why am I writing?
People want to take chances.
Let's take a selfie with the dog.
Just put it in a crate.
Super Dangerous.
It's got razor blades in its mouth.
It's just,
it's gonna make a mistake sooner or
later.
So I just,
I mean,
I,
I used to be really naive about it,
but it's interesting with German
shepherds apparently in a Ketos and I
always say if anything looks too much
like a wolf,
like be fucking super care for around
kids with it.
There's this guy that has really been
helping this guy,
Brandon Mcmillan,
he's got a show called lucky dog on cbs
and he taught me how to aggression test
dogs with two leashes and stuff that I
was just getting these dogs from
shelters that had been abused and stuff.
And I'm like,
my love isn't gonna make you trained?
No,
it's not like living in the valley with
a yard that's gonna fix you.
It's not true.
Um,
so I've learned to sort of honor,
um,
the neurology of dogs and their
instincts and they were wolves and,
and food comes first and if they have a
scarcity complex,
like they're going to go after food and
if they've been abused,
like they have no reason to not protect
themselves if they feel threatened.
Is that dog whisperer guy?
That Cesar Milan guy,
is he good or is he?
Yeah,
I mean he's like,
all these guys have,
I'm sure like any like fighting or
anything,
everyone's got logged,
that's wrong,
that's wrong.
Everyone's got their own,
like I've figured out what works for me,
which is like,
um,
uh,
basically positive reinforcement or just
ignoring the dog when they do something
wrong.
So the biggest punishment to a dog was
just ignoring them.
When you hit them,
you're actually giving them attention
and confusing them or when you yell.
Yeah,
it just,
it's confusing to them and it probably
doesn't hurt.
They usually just lose respect for you
because you,
because you've gotten into a situation
where you're now hitting them and
they're just like,
why did you let me do that yesterday?
Like,
you're the one that's inconsistent and
then they just start to feel unsafe and
anxious.
So when they do something wrong,
just ignore them for 30 minutes and they
will never do it again.
Because you read books on dogs.
I do read books on dogs.
Yeah.
Would you read books on more people or
dogs?
People,
do you?
Yeah.
Well,
I mean your dog is a reflection here.
Yeah.
Well,
I was just thinking about it sounds like
recently,
I mean,
I've read a lot of books on like
addiction and like,
yeah,
and like neuroscience that's kind of
like,
you know,
I'm finishing that book sapiens right
now,
which is that it's about like,
um,
what's the guy's name is seth,
last name seth the or something.
Um,
it's basically about evolution and how
we evolved to be the way we are.
Like his whole point is that we're a
non.
His whole point one of them that I find
interesting is like that the reason we
have so much anxiety is because we know
that we're,
um,
like we implicitly know that we're only
superficially at the top of the food
chain.
Like we don't,
we don't deserve to be at the top of the
food chain without weapons.
Like A,
if I'm in here with a gorilla alone,
I'm going to lose real quickly if I'm,
if I'm in here with a gun,
I still might lose actually.
But,
um,
but that we're all kind of like walking
around with paper thin scan and we're
incredibly vulnerable.
Um,
but we just happen to have,
you know,
the animals that kill us in cages.
I just think it's incredibly fascinating
that anatomically similar humans who
lived 10,000
years ago as we were talking about with
cro magnon who literally didn't have
very many tools or weapons,
I mean,
didn't have guns for sure.
And maybe,
I mean had adult adult or something like
that.
I don't find out when they invented the
bone arrow.
Jamie,
let's figure that out
in the bone marrow is also not a sure
thing.
You got one chance if you miss it,
you have another 10 minutes so you can
panic.
Yeah.
And you brought me.
How many times have you had to shoot a
bow and Arrow when your life depends.
I've never done it once.
That's amazing that people before then.
I mean,
so let's go back even earlier than
10,000
years ago.
Probably hope not a whole lot of
difference between those people and
people 100,000
years ago with the amount of tissue and
the softness of the body and the
vulnerability.
Like it's kind of crazy that we even
made it.
We're made of the fact that we get
through the day without a up balloons of
blood bees can kill us.
Yeah.
Bees are the literally tiniest animal.
Okay.
Bow and Arrow appears to transition from
the Upper Paleolithic to the Meso
Lithic,
so blah,
blah,
blah.
Oldest,
elegant bow.
Hold on.
What'd you do?
Extent bows in one piece
or Elm Houma.
Guard bows from Denmark,
which were dated to 9,000
BC.
Huh?
Wow.
Ece?
I like how they do that now before
current era.
It's not even about Jesus.
Wow.
Africa suggested arrows might be at
least 71,000
years old.
Holy Shit.
Wow,
that's crazy.
That is crazy.
Um,
so they had arrows for like 50,000
years for the.
Figured out the bow.
Got To do something with this.
Has this always been here?
This epidemic of fear?
I mean,
like this election.
The fear.
I'm kidding.
By the way.
I'm sure they had a po folks.
If people are going to tweet and running
now,
they're all just going back in.
History has always been here.
I mean the gun.
People want guns in their house all the
time and I'm not against people have
guns,
walls.
It is what it is.
Why are people so scared?
People are going to take their guns away
from them.
They need the guns.
There's fear.
Well,
because there are.
If I have a theory,
my biggest theory is not just that some
people live in bad neighborhoods,
but also that we're dealing with the
news of 7 billion humans.
I was just too much and we see now that
we have the news and we see so much
negative things happening that we have a
false sense of how dangerous the world
is,
where this is all bad.
We're the safest we've ever been.
Scared us.
We've ever been.
Are We?
I don't know if it was a scarce we ever
been because a lot of people are on
Xanax again.
That's true.
They'd be scared if they weren't on
Xanax,
they'd be shitting their pants,
but everyone is like,
you know,
terrified all the time and it's just
sort of an interesting thing and trying
to figure out what's a real fear and
what's a sort of reptilian irrational
fear.
Well,
it's what we were talking about before
that one day and probably not far from
now we're going to exist in some sort of
electronic state where it exists in some
sort of a weird virtual state.
Yes.
And then it's going to be interesting to
see what that state is even more
vulnerable because we'll have fucking
google glasses over our heads and we'll
our fucking spinal cord to connect it to
the matrix.
We want to have peripheral vision
anymore.
We're devolving in some way for sure.
We're definitely not.
Well,
we're evolving into a more vulnerable
thing,
which is weird.
It's not necessarily that we're
devolving because we're not becoming
more like animals.
Right.
Becoming more like,
um,
there was some study that came out that
said that kids who play video games
actually have faster reflexes and kids
who don't.
Whoa.
Yeah.
It's an interesting.
That is so maybe reflexes have to do
with the mind and the hands reacting
hand eye coordination.
Right.
That makes sense.
Like you have to move quick and.
But I mean I'm physically moving your
body side to side.
They don't have the dexterity or the
strength to do that because they're
fucking just stuck to the couch,
so they'll win.
It has to be a thumb war.
It can't be an actual threat.
I don't know what the threat was that
Jamie was talking about how they're
doing these teams for basketball that
are going to do alongside the NBA team.
Well,
no,
they're gonna play electronic basketball
alongside real basketball games.
Explain it here in the NBA is sports
league diversity means a new kind of
athlete.
Okay.
We're going to have a.
They haven't announced it fully because
every team isn't fully locked into it
yet right now.
But uh,
every team,
the idea,
the thing is every team is going to have
their own five on five video game team
and they're gonna be responsible for
signing good players and there's going
to be competitions and big that ideally
they want to have the finalists in
arenas too for this.
The finals
in arenas to do for like other games
right now,
like league of legends goes and plays in
a staple center sort of.
I'm terrified by the fact that we're
outsourcing physical sports to our
phones.
I sat next to a guy on the plane who was
playing darts on his phone starts
literally.
He was just sitting there moving his
finger show Whitney has a phone with a
photo of this guys.
So yeah,
he's just.
That was the that he thinks this is a
sport plus he's drinking.
He is shit.
Yeah.
He got shit face on him and he was also
wearing shorts,
which was really traumatizing for me,
but it was just this and I was like,
the fact that you think this is a thing
he was made.
There's just scrolling up.
The fact that he thought he was good at
darts or he was freaking out about air
travel.
So he's getting drunk and medicated and
it's distracting himself with a stupid
game.
Scares me.
I worry that we're all just zombies.
I think you should stop being so scared.
Okay.
You're right.
Just live in this moment.
Let's end it strong because we've
already done three.
Okay.
All.
I'll send this strong.
Okay.
What do we do?
So I'm going to squirt.
People are by sub miracles still
listening to this.
I really,
I,
you know,
I'm sure they are.
Do something.
Do your thing.
When we got to do this more often,
get me Outta here.
So embarrassed.
That's really fun.
It's not embarrassing at all.
Got You.
Need more positive reinforcement.
Your personal life.
I'm writing a book.
I just sit home all day and just with my
negative thoughts.
That's the problem.
Some negative.
I know.
Call me.
I'm here.
Don't worry about it.
That was going to be fun.
You're going to be fun to write a book.
Why did you let me do this?
Why would have stopped me from.
No,
no,
no.
Everything's great.
Said to me.
I said,
I was like,
are you?
Did you write a book?
And you're like,
yeah,
I gave the money back.
I was.
It was.
Didn't work for me and I was like,
well,
we're here.
The domains will do.
I should've listened to.
You know you don't.
I mean,
the problem with that I had was editors.
They were trying to get me to write
standup.
They said,
I want you to write.
First of all,
they wanted me to.
They said,
look,
you don't have to write anything.
We'll just take your stand up and we'll
transcribe it.
I go,
that's crazy.
I've already done that.
Yeah,
but they go bold.
George Carlin did that and then Jerry
Seinfeld did that.
I got,
I don't care what they did.
I'm not doing that.
Like from a write something.
I think it's a different kind of medium.
Right.
Well,
it's also,
it's interesting because you're just
sitting there bombing all day.
There's no audience.
Like my worst nightmare.
I have to wait eight months to see if
something's funny and people laugh.
Their living room.
I can't even tell if they have to
pretend the hear you say it too.
It has to like they have to have an
imagination.
It's the tone and fuck all that.
I just have to go back to up full time
because this is just like Amanda.
Everybody's wants to not do standup
fulltime.
Every comic work so hard to become a
professional class.
Then I learned my lesson.
I'm sorry he's back on back.
Come to the Ice House tomorrow night or
Wednesday night.
Tomorrow I go to Florida to Orlando.
Don't be jealous.
Well,
next time I'll come to you heard it here
folks.
It's happening weeks.
Come see me.
Eat Shit.
Alright.
Thank you bro.
It was awesome.
Whitney.
Not,
not exactly happy with it.
Look at her.
She's like,
I don't believe it was awesome.
No,
no.
It's a disaster.
Disaster.
Um,
it was great.
You're awesome.
Thank you.
Bye everybody.